I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. Today is women's appreciation. Everyone start right now. Think of a woman you appreciate. Appreciate that lady. Appreciate her. Maybe pause. Give her a text message. But appreciate a woman. Because Michael is
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨。今天是女性感谢日。大家现在就开始吧。想想一个你感激的女性。感激那位女士。感激她。也许暂停一下。发个短信给她。但一定要感激一位女性。因为迈克尔
gonna appreciate women today. He knows the crap out of women. And he's gonna appreciate them. And I'm excited. I loved this episode. I loved filming this episode. I wrote about it in my journal. Oh, lady. I can't wait. This is season 3 episode 21 written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg directed by Tucker Gates. Let's get right to it. After Phyllis is flashed in the parking lot, Michael decides to take the women to the mall to bond and unwind. The workplace was too masculine. So he wanted to take them somewhere where they could really relax. And that's the mall. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, while at the mall, Michael reveals how
今天要感谢女性。他对女性可以说是了如指掌。他要感谢她们。我太兴奋了。我很喜欢这一集。我喜欢拍摄这一集。我在日记里写过它。哦，天哪。我等不及了。这是第三季第21集，由吉恩·斯图普尼斯基和李·艾森伯格编剧，塔克·盖茨导演。我们直接切入正题吧。菲利斯在停车场被人当众闪露下体后，迈克尔决定带女员工们去商场增进感情、放松一下。工作场所太有男子气概了。所以他想带她们去一个能真正放松的地方。那就是商场。是的。哦，迈克尔。嗯，在商场里，迈克尔透露了
distressing his relationship with Jan is. Oh, distressing is a word. Yeah, I had to come up with a word for the summary. I picked distressing. Yeah. And with the support of the women, he decides to break up with her. Meanwhile, Andy and Dwight try to hang up sketches of the flasher. They're trying to find this guy. Right. The pervert. Yeah. Yep. The sketch was drawn by Pam and it heavily resembles Dwight. It's exactly Dwight. It's Dwight with a mustache. And no glasses. Oh, yeah. Finally, Kevin and the rest of the men in the office enjoy hanging out in the ladies' bathroom. Yeah. That is a crazy episode description. And that really is just
他和简的关系有多么痛苦。哦，痛苦真是一个词。是的，我得为总结想个词。我选了痛苦。是的。在女员工们的支持下，他决定和她分手。与此同时，安迪和德怀特试图张贴那个暴露狂的素描。他们正试图抓到这家伙。对。那个变态。是的。没错。那张素描是潘画的，长得极像德怀特。完全就是德怀特。那是长着胡子的德怀特。而且没戴眼镜。哦，是的。最后，凯文和办公室里的其他男士们很享受在女洗手间里闲逛。是的。这是一个疯狂的剧集简介。而这真的只是
just barely touching the surface. It really is. It really is. I mean, Meredith's van isn't in that summary. And that's a whole, that Meredith's van could be a whole episode itself. Oh, I wish we'd done an episode called Meredith's van. Wouldn't you like to see that? Yeah, exactly. Or that's a spin-off right there. Meredith's van. Just Meredith living out of her van. Yeah. What are your fast facts? Let it. Well, and my first fast fact is about you. What is it? Is it true that you once had a flasher at one of your jobs? Okay, this is true. And I told the story in the writer's room. So I was talking to Greg
刚刚触及表面。真的。确实如此。我是说，梅雷迪思的面包车不在那个总结里。那可是一大块，梅雷迪思的面包车本身就可以拍成一整集。哦，我真希望我们拍过一集叫《梅雷迪思的面包车》。难道你不想看吗？没错，完全是。或者这就是一个衍生剧。梅雷迪思的面包车。就讲梅雷迪思住在她的面包车里。是的。你的快讯是什么？说吧。嗯，我的第一个快讯是关于你的。是什么？真的是你在某份工作时遇到过暴露狂吗？好吧，这是真的。我在编剧室里讲过这个故事。所以有一天我在片场和格雷格
on set one day about just different things that happened when I worked at 1-800-Dennis as an operator. And he was like, Oh, you got to go to the writer's room. You got to tell everybody these stories. So I did. And I'm not sure that this episode is 100% from the story, but I like to think it was a little bit inspired. So I was working at 1-800-Dennis in my early 20s, which was just yesterday, Jenna, really, right? Yeah, it really was. Just yesterday. Yeah. And we had a man, he went into the women's restroom and kind of hid out in the women's restroom. And then when women would go in there, he would flash them. And who was he? We don't know. He was like some guy from the street. He was like,
聊起我在1-800-Dennis当接线员时发生的一些不同事情。然后他说，哦，你得去编剧室。你得把这些故事讲给所有人听。于是我照做了。而且我不确定这一集是否百分之百取材于这个故事，但我愿意认为它多少受到了一点启发。所以我在20岁出头的时候在1-800-Dennis工作，那就像是昨天一样，珍娜，真的，对吧？是的，真的是。就像昨天一样。是的。然后我们有个男的，他进了女洗手间，有点躲在女洗手间里。然后当女人进去时，他就会向她们闪露下体。那他是谁？我们不知道。他就像是街上的某个家伙。他就像是
went in the women's restroom. Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, how did he, where were your, did 1-800-Dennis not have their own dedicated bathroom? Was it like a whole building? It was a whole building. Yes. It was a whole building and several businesses, you know, the bathrooms were in the hallway. You know what I mean? Share bathroom. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Like when I go to a doctor's office. Exactly. Exactly. Okay. Yeah. This guy, he came in off the street and he flashed one of the ladies when she went into the bathroom and she came running out and came in the office and was like, I just got flashed. And oh my gosh, 1-800-Dennis obviously took this very seriously and they implemented a
走进了女洗手间。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。等等，他是怎么，你们的，1-800-Dennis没有他们自己的专用洗手间吗？是不是整栋楼共用的？那是整栋楼。是的。那是整栋楼，有几家公司，你知道，洗手间在走廊里。你知道我的意思吗？共用洗手间。是的。是的。是的。好吧。就像我去诊所一样。完全正确。完全正确。好吧。是的。这家伙从街上走进来，当其中一位女士走进洗手间时，他向她闪露了下体，然后她尖叫着跑出来，走进办公室说，我刚刚被人闪露了下体。天哪，1-800-Dennis显然非常严肃地对待这件事，他们实施了一个
whole new security system for our office. Okay. We are talking to people about their teeth. That's all we are doing. We're talking to people about their teeth, but guess what our security system was? Guess what the upgrade was? What? They scanned all of our fingerprints and when we got to work, there was a scanner that you put your hand on that opened up to our hallway. Oh, I put my hand there and it would go bling bling, Angela Kinsey admitted. Wow. Yeah. All because of the flasher. Yeah. But anyway, I told the writers that we had a flasher at work and it caused all this big hullabaloo. And you know, I just like to think that went on a note card on the wall somewhere. I want to give you credit for that. Oh, well, thanks. I like it. All right. Well,
全新的办公室安保系统。好吧。我们在跟人们谈论他们的牙齿。我们做的事仅此而已。我们在跟人们谈论他们的牙齿，但你猜我们的安保系统是什么？你猜升级后是什么？什么？他们扫描了我们所有的指纹，当我们去上班时，有一个扫描仪，你把手放上去，就能打开通往我们走廊的门。哦，我把手放在那儿，它就会发出叮咚的声音，安吉拉·金西承认道。哇。是的。全都是因为那个暴露狂。是的。不管怎样，我告诉编剧们我们在工作时遇到了一个暴露狂，这引起了轩然大波。你知道，我只是愿意认为那被写成了一张便签贴在墙上的某个地方。我想把功劳归给你。哦，好吧，谢谢。我喜欢。好吧。那么，
are you ready for fast fact number two? Yeah. Fast fact number two, this episode originally aired in May of 2007 and it is a super sized episode. Yes. However, when it rerun in August, they cut it down. I know. They trimmed out a bunch of stuff. Why was that? The reason this was originally a super sized episode is because this was our 50th episode of the office. Oh, wow. So it was like a little celebration. But you know, then when shows rerun, they have to be regular sized. Oh, I see. Well, to celebrate our 50th anniversary, we invited two super fan office bloggers to the set for a full day of filming so they could have a sneak peek. And do you remember who they were? Was it definitely Jenny Tan from Office Tally? Yes. And Kath is scary from Give Me
你准备好听第二个快讯了吗？是的。快讯之二，这一集最初于2007年5月播出，它是一集超长版节目。是的。然而，当它在8月重播时，他们把它剪短了。我知道。他们删减了一大堆内容。为什么会这样？这一集最初是超长版的原因是，这是我们《办公室》的第50集。哦，哇。所以这就像一个小庆祝。但你知道，当节目重播时，它们必须是常规长度。哦，我明白了。为了庆祝我们的50周年，我们邀请了两名超级粉丝办公室博主来到片场进行一整天的拍摄，这样他们就可以先睹为快。你还记得她们是谁吗？绝对是来自Office Tally的珍妮·谭吗？是的。还有来自《给我
My Remote. Oh, nice. Oh, they were so supportive of the show. I feel like they really were some of the first people organizing an online fan site where fans could go and share. Yeah. And the writers would read their sites and gather feedback like they were a big part of formulating the show. I still go to officetally.com, Jenna. Like when I'm looking up quotes when we're doing our podcast document and I'm like, oh, I want to get that exactly right, I will go to Office Tally because they usually have quotes up there. Yeah. Well, I went and looked at both of their blogs that they did after visiting the set. And I'm going to sprinkle in some of their observations as we go along in this episode. Oh, that's so fun. This is like a little time capsule. Yes, it was so cool.
我的远程控制》的卡斯·斯卡里。哦，太棒了。哦，她们太支持这部剧了。我觉得她们真的是最早组织在线粉丝网站的人，粉丝们可以在那里去分享。是的。而且编剧们会阅读她们的网站并收集反馈，就像她们是构思这部剧的重要部分一样。我到现在还会去officetally.com，珍娜。比如当我在编写播客文档时查找台词，然后我想，哦，我想把那句台词弄得完全正确，我就会去Office Tally，因为他们通常上面都有台词。好吧，我去看了一下她们俩在参观片场后写各自的博客。随着这一集的推进，我会把她们的一些观察穿插进去。哦，太有趣了。这就像一个小时间胶囊。是的，太酷了。
And by the way, okay, wait, here's one of the things that Jenny Tan wrote about her visit. This was just sort of an overview. Okay. She wrote, everybody works together really well. The actors are just incredible and they are so well prepared, knew their lines, and I didn't hear any of them once ask for a line. That's true, though. That's true. We were pros. We came up ready to play. But you know what? Steve set the bar for that. We've said that many times. She also probably couldn't see that we had our scripts hidden in our desks and we would sometimes have to sneak a look. We had to sneak a look between takes. We did do that. We did sort of like just look over them really quickly. But that's all right. That's all right. We didn't, we were
顺便说一句，好吧，等等，这是珍妮·谭对她参观之行所写的内容之一。这只是一种概述。好吧。她写道，每个人合作得非常好。演员们简直不可思议，他们准备得极其充分，台词滚瓜烂熟，我没听到他们中有任何人要求过一次对台词。不过那是真的。那是真的。我们都是专业人士。我们带着准备好的状态来演戏。但你知道吗？史蒂夫为此树立了标准。我们说过很多次了。她可能也没看到我们的剧本藏在我们的办公桌里，我们有时不得不偷偷瞄一眼。我们不得不在镜头之间偷偷看一眼。我们确实这么做过了。我们差不多就是快速地扫一眼。但这没关系。没关系。我们从没有过，我们
never like line. Can I get my line? What's my line? Yeah. So yeah. And then Angela, another thing I thought was really interesting. She noted that you had a 430 a.m. call time that day. Those first few seasons, I was almost always at 430 because we didn't have the budget that we then ultimately gained and we hired more hair and makeup people. So they would stack us super early in the morning. Kate Flannery and I always were there at 430. I remember that. And then this also I thought was kind of funny. She wrote this. Jenna mentioned more than once on her MySpace blog that she sometimes wears sweatpants and her uggs when she knows she's only being shot from the waist up and it's true. She wanted, she confirmed that I only got half dressed. Our set was so cold. I know. I know.
从来没有说过“台词”这种话。我能拿到我的台词吗？我的台词是什么？是的。所以，是的。然后，安吉拉，我注意到另一件非常有趣的事。她指出那天你早上4点30分就要到片场。头几季里，我几乎总是4点30分到，因为我们当时没有后来最终获得的预算，也没有雇佣更多的发型和化妆师。所以他们会把我们排在清晨超级早的时间。凯特·弗兰内里和我总是4点30分到那儿。我记得。然后这个我也觉得挺搞笑的。她写了这些。珍娜在她的MySpace博客上不止一次提到，当她知道自己只需要拍上半身时，她有时会穿运动裤和UGG雪地靴，这是真的。她想，她证实了我只穿了一半衣服。我们的片场太冷了。我知道。我知道。
So anyway, I am really excited because I'm going to sprinkle some of their observations in throughout the episode. All right. So what's FastFact number three? FastFact number three is a location breakdown based on this fan question from Devah Crane, Sophia Bahena, Cassandra Irochetta, Mary Ruff, and Jocelyn Izaguire. They all asked, did you film in a real mall? Where was it? Did you have to close it down or did you film with real patrons? Now, Ange, I usually go to Kentopedia. But you didn't need to this time, lady. You didn't need to because this was our mall. This was our mall, you guys. Literally, this is the mall in our neighborhood where we lived. Angela and I have been to this mall in real life 90 gazillion times. Many, many times together separately. Sometimes
所以无论如何，我真的很兴奋，因为我会在这一集里穿插他们的一些观察。好吧。那么第三个快讯是什么？快讯之三是一个根据德瓦·克兰、索菲亚·巴埃纳、卡桑德拉·伊罗切塔、玛丽·拉夫和乔斯林·伊扎吉雷的粉丝提问整理的拍摄地点解析。他们都问，你们是在真正的商场里拍摄的吗？是在哪里？你们不得不把它清场吗，还是和真正的顾客一起拍摄的？安吉，我通常会去肯特百科。但你这次不需要了，女士。你不需要，因为这就是我们的商场。这就是我们的商场，伙计们。字面意义上讲，这就是我们生活社区里的商场。安吉拉和我在现实生活中去过这个商场九千万次。一起去过很多很多次，也各自去过。有时
we'd have a BFF date. Yes. This was Fashion Square Mall in Studio City. It was like three miles from my house. Oh, yeah. We went all the time. We knew the layout. We knew when they said, okay, ladies, we're going to start the morning in the food court. You and I were like, I wonder where they're going to see this. Maybe over by Panda Express. Are they going to put us over in the corner? I bet they put us in the corner. Yeah. We knew the layout. We knew the layout, of course. And guys, we did not close down the whole mall for filming. No. No, people were there. We started crazy early, though. In the food court. Yeah. And we started upstairs. There was like an upper level of the food court. And we had that whole upper level to ourselves. And it didn't
我们会来个闺蜜约会。是的。这就是工作室城的时尚广场购物中心。离我家大概三英里远。哦，是的。我们经常去。我们知道这里的布局。我们知道当他们说，好的，女士们，我们要在美食广场开始早晨的拍摄时。你和我会想，我不知道他们会在哪里拍这个。也许在熊猫快餐旁边？他们要把我们安排在角落里吗？我打赌他们会把我们安排在角落里。是的。我们知道布局。当然，我们知道布局。伙计们，我们拍摄时并没有把整个商场清场。没有。没有，那里有人。不过我们开始得疯狂地早。在美食广场。是的。而且我们是在楼上开始的。美食广场好像有个上层。整个上层都是我们自己的。而且直到
open until like 11am. But we had to be done so they could open the food court on time. I remember that. Yeah. I wrote that we were seated in the food court filming at 7am. Yeah. Yes. And all the people in that food court were hired background performers. But later, when we went into the mall, all the people sort of passing behind us, like behind your talking head, behind Steve's talking head, those were just people in the mall. Yeah. They couldn't close that main part of the mall, right? So we were just navigating around them and we were filming. And that, this is a thing I wrote in my journal, Jenna, is that we really realized what a big star Steve was. Like, we knew, we knew he had become a big star. You know, he had these movies coming out and they were big hits.
大约上午11点才营业。但我们必须在美食广场按时开门前拍完。我记得。是的。我写道我们在上午7点坐在美食广场拍摄。是的。是的。美食广场里的所有人都是雇来的背景演员。但后来，当我们进入商场时，所有那些从我们身后走过的人，比如在你的访谈镜头后面，在史蒂夫的访谈镜头后面，那些就只是商场里的人。是的。他们无法封闭商场的那主要部分，对吧？所以我们只是在他们周围穿梭并进行拍摄。而且，我在日记里写过一件事，珍娜，那就是我们真正意识到史蒂夫是一个多么大的明星。就像，我们知道，我们知道他已经成了一个大明星。你知道，他有这些即将上映的电影，而且都是大热片。
But being at that shopping mall to him, we really got a window into what his life was like now. Because no one yelled our names. No one, Jenna, no, people were walking right past us. But they would see Steve and they would start to yell at him, Steve, Steve, I wrote that someone yelled, I love lamp. Oh yeah, that line from Anchorman. Yes. And we were like, Oh my God, Steve, that guy's yelling at you about the lamp. And he goes, I know. Yeah. Yeah. That was crazy. Yeah. That was crazy. I do remember though, that they shut down the victorious secret for us. We had the whole store. Yeah, we felt very fancy about that. That was very exciting to have a whole store to yourself. That was so cool. And then we also had one level of the parking garage. And they put all our trailers
但对他来说，在那个购物中心里，我们真正得以一窥他现在的生活是怎样的。因为没有人喊我们的名字。没有人，珍娜，不，人们就从我们身边走过。但他们会看到史蒂夫，然后他们会开始冲他喊，史蒂夫，史蒂夫，我写道有人喊道，我爱台灯。哦，对，来自《王牌播音员》的那句台词。是的。然后我们就想，哦，天哪，史蒂夫，那家伙在冲你喊台灯的事。然后他说，我知道。是的。是的。那太疯狂了。是的。那太疯狂了。不过我确实记得，他们为我们关闭了维多利亚的秘密。我们包下了整间店。是的，我们对此感到非常时髦。能独占一整家店真是令人兴奋。太酷了。然后我们还占用了停车场的一层。他们把所有的房车都停在那里
there. We ate lunch there. They set up the catering. And then we also were able to bring in our own cars to do that scene with Meredith. Yeah. Parking. Yeah. But we really, we really just spent the whole day at the mall. We really did. We really did. And lady, by the way, I'm going to point it out, but there oftentimes you can see you and I walking in the background together. Yeah. Of different shots. And our characters should not be walking together. No. In the background shopping. No, we were just kind of, we were just hanging out. We were probably saying this, listen, we should come back tomorrow because did you see the sale? We were 100% doing that. We were Kelly at the mall. Yeah. If we have a break, maybe we can sneak in there. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
我们在那里吃午饭。他们设置了餐饮区。然后我们还可以开着我们自己的车去拍和梅雷迪思一起的那场戏。是的。停车。是的。但我们真的，我们真的在商场里度过了整整一天。真的度过了。确实如此。女士，顺便说一句，我要指出的是，很多时候你可以看到你和我一起走在背景里。是的。在不同的镜头里。而我们的角色本不应该一起走路。不。在背景里购物。不，我们只是有点，我们只是闲逛。我们可能在说这个，听着，我们明天应该回来，因为你看到那个促销了吗？我们百分之百在那样做。我们在商场里的凯利。是的。如果我们有休息时间，也许我们可以偷偷溜进去。是的。是的。我是说，
I feel like we did some shopping that day. I was going to say, I feel like I came home with something from Macy's. I know. I know. I'm pretty sure. All right. Well, ladies, should we take a break and then we come back? We will really, really break down this episode. I might have tracked something. We might need to discuss it. That is the best news I've heard all day. I can't wait to track something with you. You might change your mind. Oh, no. All right. We'll be back. And we are back. We start with a cold open Jenna that was originally written for the business school episode. What? Yes. The cold open where Jim comes in and he's tardy and Dwight is going to write him up. That was originally for the business school episode and the Dwight and Jim
我觉得我们那天买了一些东西。我正想说，我觉得我回家时手里拿着梅西百货的东西。我知道。我知道。我敢肯定。好吧，女士们，我们要不要休息一下再回来？我们将真正、真正地剖析这一集。我可能追踪到了什么东西。我们可能需要讨论一下。这是我今天听到最好的消息。我迫不及待想跟你一起追踪点什么了。你可能会改变主意。哦，不。好吧。我们马上回来。我们回来了。珍娜，我们从一个最初为商学院那一集写的外景开场开始。什么？是的。吉姆进来迟到了，而德怀特要记他过失的那个外景开场。那是原本为商学院那一集准备的，而德怀特和吉姆
dressing like each other was supposed to be for this episode, but they switched them for time. Wow. Yeah. Well, you know, they would do these cold opens and they were meant to be standalone. They were meant to be their own encapsulated joke that really didn't interfere with the main plot of an episode. So I guess they were kind of interchangeable in a way. Now, sometimes the cold open did affect the plot, but you know, to standalone cold opens, I guess you can put them wherever you want. And I feel like the tag in this episode is plot related. So I think it was for the best. Yes, I agree. All right. So Jenna, here's the thing. Do you know that if you're tardy, you will get three demerits. Yep. And then you'll receive a citation. Yeah. Yeah. And then
互相模仿着穿对方衣服的那场戏本来是为这一集准备的，但为了时间原因，他们把这两段对调了。哇。是的。好吧，你知道，他们会拍这些外景开场，它们本来就是独立的。它们本来就是自成一体的笑话，不会真正干扰一集的主要情节。所以我想它们在某种程度上是可以互换的。现在，有时外景开场确实会影响情节，但是，你知道，作为独立的外景开场，我想你可以把它们放在任何你想放的地方。我觉得这一集的尾声与情节有关。所以我觉得这样安排最好。是的，我同意。好吧。那么，珍娜，事情是这样的。你知道如果你迟到了，你将获得三个违纪记分吗？是的。然后你会收到一张传票。是的。是的。然后
five citations and you're going to get a violation, which is bad because tell us what happens after that. Four violations and you're going to get a verbal warning. Oh no. Yeah. Keep it up. You're going to get a written warning. Yeah. Two written warnings and you're going to be in a world hurt in the form of a disciplinary review. And that disciplinary review is going to be written by Dwight and placed on the desk of his immediate superior. Who by the way is Jim? Who is tardy? Right. It's going to take a week worth of like paperwork. I mean, this just made me laugh so hard. I just feel like I know these people. I feel like I know a Dwight. I feel like I worked with a Dwight, like someone who has such a small amount of control and takes it so seriously. It's
五次传票你就会得到一次违规，这很糟糕，因为告诉我们这之后会发生什么。四次违规你会得到一次口头警告。哦，不。是的。继续这样下去。你会收到书面警告。是的。两次书面警告，你就会陷入纪律审查形式的水深火热之中。而那次纪律审查将由德怀特撰写，并放在他的直接上司的桌上。顺便问一下，上司是谁？吉姆？他迟到了？对。这需要一周时间的文书工作。我的意思是，这简直把我笑死。我觉得我认识这些人。我觉得我认识一个德怀特，我觉得我曾和某个德怀特共事过，比如那种拥有极少权力却将其当成天大事情的人。这
just so ridiculously perfect. I love it. This episode opens with Phyllis arriving to work and she is clearly upset. And by the way, I really like how all of us are genuinely kind to Phyllis and concerned for her. Yeah. Yeah. She's shaken up and we're worried about her. And Jenna, before we get into the scene, I have to share something with you that has become part of our family. It's like a family story. You know those stories in your family that you retell over and over, you know? Yeah. Well, this episode inspired one of those family stories for me that we get together and retell at family reunions and everyone just cracks up. What is it? All right, Jenna, you know, my grandmother, Lena Mackenzie, she was a very, very proper, classy Southern lady.
简直荒谬得完美。我太喜欢了。这一集以菲利斯来上班开场，她明显心烦意乱。顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢我们所有人对菲利斯都发自内心地友善并且为她担心。是的。是的。她受到了惊吓，我们在为她担心。珍娜，在我们进入这场戏之前，我必须跟你分享一件已经成为我们家族一部分的事情。这就像一个家族故事。你知道你家族里那些你一遍又一遍重述的故事，你知道的吗？是的。这一集为我激发了其中一个家族故事，我们在家族聚会上聚在一起重述它，每个人都笑得前仰后合。是什么？好吧，珍娜，你知道，我的外祖母，莉娜·麦肯齐，她是一位非常、非常端庄、优雅的南方女士。
Yes. And, you know, she was not a fan of the office. She thought that Michael Scott was vulgar and she would say to me, Angela, we are so proud of you, but I don't care for it and I do not watch it, but we are so proud of you. I remember. So my parents were really getting into the show and they were like, Lena May, you got to give it another shot. We gave it another shot and now we like it. You got to watch this week's episode. Oh no. I call home. I'm like, hey, mom, are you going to watch this week? We are and we told your grandmother to watch. We got it on right now. I said, oh no, mom, not this week. Not this week for grandmother. Oh no. She was like, why not? And I said, because Phyllis gets flashed and it's all we talk about. What did your grandma
是的。而且，你知道，她不是《办公室》的粉丝。她认为迈克尔·斯考特很粗俗，她会对我说，安吉拉，我们为感到你骄傲，但我不喜欢这个，我也不看它，不过我们为你感到骄傲。我记得。所以我的父母真的很迷这部剧，他们说，莉娜·梅，你得再给它一次机会。我们给了它一次机会，现在我们喜欢它。你得看本周这一集。哦，不。我打电话回家。我说，嘿，妈妈，你打算看本周的节目吗？我们看了，而且我们叫你外祖母看了。我们现在就正放着呢。我说，哦，不，妈妈，这周不行。外祖母千万别看这周的。哦，不。她就问，为什么不呢？我说，因为菲利斯被人闪露了下体，而且我们整集都在谈论这个。你奶奶看这一集时说了什么？
say when she watched this episode? Well, she never watched another episode. Did she? I called home the next day and I said, hey, mom, did you talk to grandmother? Did she watch it? She said, I did and this is what she said. And I wrote it down and I have it in my journal. This is what my grandmother said. I watched it right up until they started talking about penises and then I turned it off. That was probably good. She turned it off because I mean, we didn't want her to be subjected to that scene in the mall when Michael describes his sex life with jam. Oh my God. When he's like, what is a pap smear? I'm glad my grandmother didn't make it that far. Do you want to know when she turned it off? Yes. Four minutes, 25 seconds is the first time we say the word penis.
嗯，她再也没看另一集。真的吗？我第二天打电话回家说，嘿，妈妈，你跟外祖母谈过吗？她看了吗？她说，我看了，这就是她说的。我把它写下来了，记在我的日记里。我外祖母是这么说的。我一直看到他们开始谈论阴茎，然后我就把它关掉了。那可能挺好的。她把它关掉了，因为我是说，我们不想让她经受商场里迈克尔描述他和简的性生活的那场戏。天哪。当他说，什么是巴氏涂片检查？我很高兴我外祖母没看到那么远。你想知道她什么时候关掉的吗？是的。4分25秒是我们第一次说出“阴茎”这个词。
Click. Bye-bye. She checked out. She was done. And I mean, up until that point, you know, we're talking about how Phyllis has been flashed and where he put it on the map. Oh my God, Jenna, do you remember that Phyllis could not get through that? Do you remember that? No. Which part? She broke every time she said he had it out on the map. She could not get through it. She was laughing so hard. Well, I remember it was very difficult to get through Creed saying, what's the big deal? He's hanging brain. That like that phrase hanging brain. It's so gross. It's so gross. But then Michael comes in and he finds out what happens and he is like completely not sympathetic at all. And Phyllis isn't even there anymore. Phyllis has gone off with Bob Vance. He's taking
咔哒。拜拜。她不看了。她受够了。我是说，在那之前，你知道，我们在谈论菲利斯是如何被闪露下体的，以及他把那东西掏出来放在了地图上。天哪，珍娜，你还记得菲利斯根本演不下去吗？你记得吗？不。哪部分？每次她说“他把那东西掏出来放在了地图上”时，她都笑场了。她根本演不下去。她笑得太厉害了。好吧，我记得克里德说“这有什么大不了的？他在晃荡命根子”时非常难拍下去。就像“晃荡命根子”这个词。太恶心了。太恶心了。但接着迈克尔进来了，他发现发生了什么，他完全一点都不同情。而且菲利斯甚至已经不在那儿了。菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯一起走了。他带
her for a walk to calm her down. But Michael comes in and he is just making a joke of it. And he puts his finger in his pants through the zipper of his pants to look like a penis. And I remember we all thought there's no way this is making this on TV. Well, Jenna, I was super curious about how we were able to get this on the air. So I went to the DVD commentary to see if they said anything. And they did say there was one specific thing we had to do by standards and practices rules. Oh, really? This went all the way to standards and practices. Should we tell them what standards and practices is? Yeah, well, there's like, there's certain rules about what you can and cannot broadcast on network television.
她去散步以让她平静下来。但迈克尔进来了，他只是在拿这开玩笑。他把手指塞进裤子拉链里，看起来像个阴茎。我记得我们所有人都觉得这绝不可能播上电视。好吧，珍娜，我超级好奇我们是怎么把这个搬上电视的。所以我去看了DVD评论音轨，看看他们有没有说什么。他们确实说过有一件特定事情我们必须按照审查标准与实务规则去做。哦，真的是这样吗？这一直闹到了审查标准与实务部门。我们要不要告诉他们什么是审查标准与实务部门？好吧，嗯，就像，有一些关于网络电视上能广播什么和不能广播什么的特定规则。
Well, according to the DVD commentary, this was the one thing we had to do by standards and practices. Before Michael turns around with his finger in his the fly of his pants. Yeah. Camera has to see him fully extend his hand outside of his pants. And then watch his hand go in his pants through his fly. So you know, beyond a shadow of a doubt, that is Michael's hand. You'll see Michael turns around and you have a close up of his hand and what and he's kind of fidgeting so that we all know it's his hand. And that was because standards and practices said that's the only way we'll let the scene play. Wow. I know. I still can't believe that we got away with it. And then what I really can't believe is that when Toby walks in, the finger goes down. Yes. Well, fan catch from Breanne,
好吧，根据DVD评论音轨，这是我们为了符合审查标准与实务规则必须做的一件事。在迈克尔转过身把手指塞进裤门之前。是的。镜头必须看到他的手完全伸出裤子外面。然后看着他的手通过裤门伸进裤子里。所以你要毫无疑问地确凿知道那是迈克尔的手。你会看到迈克尔转过身，你有一个他手部特写的镜头，而且他有点在摆弄，这样我们都知道那是他的手。那是审查标准与实务部门要求的，他们说那是让这场戏播出的唯一方式。哇。我知道。我还是不敢相信我们竟然蒙混过关了。然后我真正不敢相信的是，当托比走进来时，那根手指就放下去了。是的。来自布里安、
Catherine, Julie, Elizabeth and Christina, everyone noticed that in the background of this exchange between Michael and Toby, it's sort of near the end after Toby's walked away and Michael is apologizing. John Krasinski is visibly red in the face and laughing into his hand. He is flat out breaking. And not only that, I love this fan catch because I wrote a timecode down between four minutes and 36 seconds and four minutes, 40 seconds. I see John, not Jim, look right to Randall, our camera operator. Yes, I thought the same thing. I thought that is not Jim glancing to camera. That is John glancing at Randall. Yes, because it's just above camera. You know, it's not right down the barrel, which is where he would normally glance. He's looking at Randall
凯瑟琳、朱莉、伊丽莎白和克里斯蒂娜的粉丝捕捉，每个人都注意到在迈克尔和托比这段对话的背景中，大概是在托比走开之后、迈克尔在道歉的时候。约翰·卡拉辛斯基的脸明显红了，正把脸埋进手里笑。他彻底笑场了。不仅如此，我喜欢这个粉丝捕捉，因为我在4分36秒到4分40秒之间记下了时间码。我看到约翰，不是吉姆，正看着兰德尔，我们的摄像师。是的，我也这么想。我以为那不是吉姆在瞥向镜头。那是约翰在看兰德尔。是的，因为那在摄像机正上方。你知道，那不是直接对着镜头，他通常会那样瞥镜头。他是在看兰德尔
trying not to break. And Randall was probably breaking too, but they're having a moment. And the line that really made him go is when Michael says, as that was coming out of my mouth, I knew that it was wrong. Well, now Michael has a talking head where he explains that in all of the excitement, he forgot that his primary concern is keeping the people in his office safe and that women just can't have fun if they don't feel safe. And he knows this because, you know, he and Jan have a safe word, which is foliage. What is happening in that bedroom? I don't know. What is happening that he has a safe word that she doesn't pay attention to? What is happening? I don't know. Oh, Lord. Oh, and then Jan's phone call. She like wants his body. She's going to leave
努力不笑场。而且兰德尔可能也在笑场，但他们正在经历一个时刻。真正让他破功的那句台词是，当迈克尔说，当那句话从我嘴里说出来时，我就知道那是错的。好吧，现在迈克尔有一个访谈镜头，他在其中解释说，在所有的兴奋中，他忘记了首要任务是确保办公室里的人安全，而且女性如果感到不安全就根本无法开心。他之所以知道这一点，是因为，你知道，他和简有一个安全词，叫作树叶。那个卧室里到底在发生什么？我不知道。到底发生了什么，他有一个安全词而她根本不理睬？到底在发生什么？我不知道。哦，天哪。哦，还有简的电话。她想要他的身体。她要给他200美元、300美元。她会去弄更多伏特加。亨特，你在通话吗？这一切都太可怕了。
him $200, $300. She'll get more vodka. Hunter, are you on the call? Like everything about this is horrifying. Lady, I have to say that that thing of like Hunter, are you on the call? That has happened to me in business calls where I'll be talking to my agent or to my manager. And I'm having what I think is like a private candid conversation. And all of a sudden, like 20 minutes in, they'll ask their assistant, did you get that? Can you go ahead and set that meeting? And the assistant's like, no problem. I'll put it in the calendar. And I'm like, wait, what? What is that thing? Your assistant just listens to our phone calls. That's a thing. Man, oh, man, I couldn't be an assistant. I couldn't handle that information. It would be
女士，我不得不说，像“亨特，你在通话吗？”这种事。我在商务电话中也遇到过，当时我会和我的经纪人或经理交谈。我正在进行我认为是私人坦诚的对话。突然之间，大概进行了20分钟，他们会问他们的助手，你听到了吗？你能去安排那个会议吗？然后助手说，没问题。我会把它记在日历里。然后我就想，等等，什么？那是什么情况？你的助手一直在听我们的电话吗？有这回事。天哪，天哪，我可当不了助手。我应付不了那些信息。如果我必须偷听，而我的老板正在和某人对话，而且对话变得有点个人化或激烈，对我来说会很难，你知道，不插话进去，比如，你知道，你可能只需要花上一分钟，在开口之前深呼吸，你知道的，不要说你会后悔的话。他们会说，那是谁？好吧，我们在5分47秒有一个很好的前后呼应。是的，一些粉丝也捕捉到了这一点，安吉拉，德怀特正在停车场，他正用那根他为了商学院而做的削尖的、挖空的扫帚柄刺戳灌木丛，当时他担心吉姆会变成吸血鬼。是的，他留着它。他当然留着它。他可能用大力胶带把它粘在办公桌底下了。
so hard for me not to interject. Like if I had to listen in and my boss was having a conversation with someone and it got like sort of personal or heated, it'd be so hard for me, you know, to not be like, you know, you might try just taking a minute, take a breath before you, you know, don't say something you're going to regret. They'd be like, who is that? Well, we have a nice callback at five minutes, 47 seconds. Yes, we had some fans catch this as well, Angela Dwight is down in the parking lot and he is stabbing the shrubbery with that pointed, carved out broom handle that he made for business school when he was worried that Jim was becoming a vampire. Yeah, he kept it. Of course he kept it. He probably duct taped it under his desk.
这也被雷妮·布朗、史蒂芬斯、贝瑟尼·A、菲比·托马克和雅各布·赫希等人捕捉到了。好吧。所以，珍娜，现在是6分29秒。迈克尔和德怀特决定成立一个新的反暴露狂特别工作组。他们出来宣布了这个消息。我想让你知道，雷恩·威尔逊在这场戏里笑得太厉害了。珍娜，我想我们，我想我们拍了大概15或16条。你还记得他哪句台词怎么也过不去吗，因为我永远不会忘记。我永远不会忘记。而且它在片花里。哦，太棒了。说出来，珍娜。所以他说我们应该在停车场安装泛光灯。是的。然后他说，我知道，我知道你们在想什么。那会照亮更多的
Well, that was caught also by Renee Brown and Stevens, Bethany A, Phoebe Tomak and Jacob Hirsch among others. All right. So Jenna, now it's six minutes, 29 seconds. Michael and Dwight have decided they are going to form a new anti flashing task force. They come out and announce this. And I want you to know, Rainn Wilson broke so hard throughout this scene. Jenna, I think we, I think we did like 15 or 16 takes. Do you remember what line he could not get through because I will never forget it. I'll never forget it. And it's on the bloopers. Oh, it's so good. Say it, Jenna. So he says that we should install floodlights in the parking lot. Yeah. And then he says, I know, I know what you're thinking. Well, that shed more light on the
阴茎。我们怎么也拍不过这句台词。当我重看并再次听到他说时。是的。我就想，我们的台词太天才、太荒谬了。我知道。抱歉，这只是让我笑死。而且这一切，这一切都太完美了。然后他不得不说，潘，你可以用……来麻痹它。你就像是，阴茎，菲利斯。抱歉，我脑子里全是阴茎。然后吉姆瞥向镜头。整个时刻写得太美妙了，表演得也太棒了。是的。导致这种荒谬感的另一件事是，你原本预料德怀特会有可怕的想法。但他的想法一开始非常棒。很聪明。这种安装泛光灯的想法，这种增加安全摄像头的想法。我记得导演指导我给菲利斯一个眼神，
penises. We could not get through that line. When I was rewatching and I heard him say it again. Yeah. I was like, we could have line is so genius and absurd. I know. Sorry, it just cracks me up. And all of it, all of it was so perfect. And then him having to say, Pam, you can drug it with phallus. You're like, phallus phillus. Sorry, I just have penises on the brain. And then Jim's looked a camera. This whole moment is just so beautifully written and performed. Yes. And the other thing that led to the absurdity of it is that you're expecting Dwight to have horrible ideas. But his ideas start off really good. Smart. This idea of floodlights, this idea of extra security cameras. And I remember being directed to give a look to phillus,
就像是安慰的眼神，“嘿，他们不会把这事彻底搞砸的。”然后事情就变得诡异又好笑。是的。他一开始表现得太好了。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，所以潘要去找菲利斯。她要画一幅素描，不过菲利斯记不清任何细节了。潘就说，没关系。我只是不想接电话。是的。但接着凯伦进来了，现在我们听到了德怀特那奇葩的想法清单。所以，他最初宣布的正是商业园区为应对这种情况计划做的事情。而现在我们听到的是德怀特的指令。是的。德怀特的指令基本上就是把女员工锁起来，把所有的香蕉都扔掉。是的。到底怎么了？是的。他开始说女员工必须以某种方式着装。她们
like reassuring like, hey, they're not going to totally mess this up. And then it just gets weird and so funny. Yeah. He starts out so well. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Well, so Pam is going to meet up with Phyllis. And she's going to make a sketch, except that Phyllis can't really remember any details. And Pam's like, it's fine. I just don't feel like answering the phone. Yeah. But then Karen enters and now we get Dwight's weird list of ideas. So like what he was announcing originally is what the business park was planning to do to help the situation. And now we're getting Dwight's mandate. Yeah. Dwight's mandate is basically lock up the women and get rid of all the bananas. Yeah. What is happening? Yes. He starts saying that like the women have to dress a certain way. They
必须穿长袖到手腕的衣服，颜色要朴素。潘就说，没人那样穿。然后镜头转向安吉拉，这是一个剧本里非常搞笑的时刻。我记得这是其中的一个时刻，珍娜，看起来很简单，但排练得非常仔细，因为B摄像机必须找到我并放大，对吧？这是一个很快的，非常快的一闪而过的镜头，而且必须，你知道，对准焦距。所以这是一个非常微小的时刻，但对于我会站在哪里经过了精确的构思。而且全都是踩着你的台词的时间点。我想让你知道，既然我们在谈论我穿的衣服，在8分28秒时，你就能看到我的服装，我们的服装设计师凯瑞·贝内特和我玩得太开心了。我们当时兴奋极了。
have to wear sleeves down to their wrists, muted colors. And Pam is like, no one dresses like that. And then the camera swings over to Angela, which is a very funny moment that was in the script. And I remember this was one of those moments, Jenna, that it looks simple, but it was very choreographed because the B camera had to find me and zoom in, right? And it's a quick, it's a very quick whip over and it had to, you know, be in focus. So that's a really tiny moment, but it was very thought out exactly where I would stand. And it was all timed off of your line. And I want you to know, since we're talking about what I have on, that at eight minutes, 28 seconds is when you see my outfit that our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett and I had so much fun. We were giddy.
当她拿到剧本，上面写着我要穿这件猫咪毛衣和这套衣服时，我们简直等不及了。我试穿了所有这些不同的毛衣。这是我们挑的一件。你可能看不太出来，但每只猫都非常不同且独一无二。毛衣上的其中一只猫身上背着一个串珠手提包。另一只猫戴着像耳罩一样的东西，但那些耳罩是那种蓬松的，你知道吗？哇。是的。我真希望我还留着那件毛衣。我跟凯瑞聊过她去哪里为你买的衣服？她在哪里找到这些东西的？你知道她对我说什么吗？什么？她说你的很多毛衣和那种蓬松的衬衫都是复古款。是真的。那是真的。而且它们没有替补款。只有一件。
When she got the script and it said, I would be wearing this like cat sweater and this outfit, we just couldn't wait. And I tried on all these different sweaters. This is the one we picked. And you can't really tell, but each of the cat is very different and distinct. And one of the cats on the sweater had a beaded purse that it was carrying. One of the other cats had like earmuffs, but the earmuffs were like poofy, you know? Wow. Yeah. I wish I still had that sweater. I talked to Carrie about where did she shop for you? Where did she find the stuff? And you know what she told me? What? She said that a lot of your sweaters and your floofy blouses were vintage. That's true. That is true. And there was no double for them. There was just one.
是的。这会让她有点紧张，因为如果你把咖啡洒在上面什么的，她就有麻烦了。但这就是她找到这些奇特小物件的方式。而且，她说复古服装通常尺码偏小。所以对她来说实际上需要修改的地方更少。是的，那是真的。每当我穿的毛衣或衬衫没有替补款时，她都会告诉我。我总是确保，珍娜，在午饭时换衣服。我从来不在吃饭时穿着这些衣服，因为我们经常没有备用服装。我记得。我还记得有时你，安吉拉，如果我们时间紧迫，你会在胸前做一个非常复杂的类似餐巾围兜的东西，因为你太担心了。有时由于某种原因我们时间很紧，
Yeah. And it would make her a little nervous because if you spilled coffee on it or something, she was going to be in trouble. But that was how she found these weird little items. And also, she said vintage clothing usually runs smaller. And so it was fewer alterations for her actually. Yes, that is true. And she would let me know when whatever sweater or blouse I had didn't have a double. And I always made sure, Jenna, to change at lunch. I never ate in my clothes because we often didn't have a match for it. I remember that. I also remember you sometimes, Angela, if we were rushing, you would do this really elaborate like napkin bib thing on the front of you because you were so worried. I would take sometimes we were rushing for whatever reason,
我没时间跑回我的房车去换衣服。我会拿大概八张餐巾纸，把它们塞在领子周围一直塞到胳肢窝。我看起来像个疯子。现在办公室里的女员工们对德怀特真的很生气，对吧？这些规则太荒谬了。然后迈克尔出来了，他对德怀特很生气。他说，你知道吗？感谢女性会议在会议室举行。他有资格感谢女性。因为他来自一个女人。是的。他跟不止一个女人上过床。少于三个。好吧，这不是准确的信息，他说。是的。而且，他只是对女性了解得透透的，安吉拉。我知道。女性需要的是“尊重”（RESPCT）。这就是她们需要的。菲利斯听到这话时的表情太精彩了。
and I didn't have time to run to my trailer and change. I would get like eight napkins and tuck them around my collar all the way to my armpit. I looked insane. So now the women in the office, they're really upset with Dwight, right? These rules are ridiculous. And Michael comes out, he's upset with Dwight. He's like, you know what? Women's appreciating meeting in the conference room. He's qualified to appreciate women. Because he came from a woman. Yeah. He has slept with more than one woman. Less than three. Well, that's not accurate information, he says. Yeah. But also, he just knows the crap out of women, Angela. I know. What women need is RESPCT. That's what they need. Phyllis' face when he says that is so amazing.
她的脸上掠过一个微小的表情，仿佛在说，哈？来自泰勒·西格拉夫斯和珍娜·奥尔德里奇的粉丝提问：当迈克尔拼出“尊重”（RESPCT）时，那是即兴发挥还是剧本写好的？剧本里写着他正确地拼出了这个词。然后每次拍摄，他都会用不同的方式来演。我们怎么也过不去。这是另一个时刻。史蒂夫就是那样的人，你知道。他就像喜剧刺客。他会按照剧本拿过来，然后进行即兴发挥。你永远不知道他会做什么。这让人很难保持扑克脸。是的。另外，在这场戏中，安吉拉·德怀特正在吃一根香蕉。是的。这就是他从厨房拿的那根。
She gets this little look that washes over her face like, huh? Fan question from Taylor Seagraves and Jenna Aldridge. When Michael spells out RESPCT, was that improv or scripted? It was scripted that he spelled it out correctly. And then every take, he would do it differently. We couldn't get through it. This was another moment. That's what Steve would do, though. You know, he was like the comedy assassin. He would like take it as it was written, and then he would play around with it. And you could never know what he was going to do. And it made it so hard to keep a straight face. Yes. Also, during this scene, Angela Dwight is eating a banana. Yeah. And this is one of the ones he's taken from the kitchen.
来自GiveMeMyRemote.com的卡特在她的博客中指出，每次我们开始新的一条拍摄时，雷恩都必须吃一根新香蕉。我们这场戏拍了很多条。那天她在片场问雷恩吃所有这些香蕉是什么感觉。他说这让他感到恶心，他可能再也不会吃香蕉了。这让他倒尽胃口。这倒是有可能。是的。而且他很早就做出了一个重大决定，那就是狼吞虎咽地吃香蕉，这是一个非常、非常搞笑的选择。然后他不得不重复这个过程。但这就是他让德怀特吃东西的方式。雷恩，这是你自找的。我们别忘了还有煎饼。接下来我们还有一块糖果。德怀特做事从不敷衍。如果他要吃什么东西，他就会把它吃完。是的。这是真的。
Kath, from GiveMeMyRemote.com, noted in her blog that rain had to eat a new banana every time we started over a new take. And we did a lot of takes of this scene. She asked rain on set that day how it was to eat all the bananas. And he said it was making him sick and he may never eat another banana again. It turned on him. That would happen. Yeah. And he made a big choice early on, which was to devour the banana, which was a very, very funny choice. And he had to repeat it then. But that is how he made Dwight eat. Rain, you did this to yourself. Let's not forget the pancakes. And then we have a candy bar coming up. Dwight does nothing half-assed. If he's going to eat something, he eats it. Yeah. That's true.
抱歉，我在对你大喊大叫。我喜欢。尽管来吧。我对德怀特吃东西的方式感到非常激动。好吧，现在会议在会议室里进行了。迈克尔像一只鸟一样栖息在他的椅子上。9分36秒。史蒂夫怎么能这样坐？我不知道。他是怎么做到的？他总是能找到最尴尬的方式坐着和站着。这太搞笑了。好吧，他为所有没有把这事当回事的男士们道歉。克里德仍然不明白这有什么大不了的。但迈克尔解释说，没有人喜欢被当众闪露下体。不仅是女性。当梅雷迪思在圣诞派对期间向他闪露下体时，他恶心坏了。他恨透了。是的。但听着，他还想让我们知道，在正确的语境下，阴茎对女性来说是最美妙的景象。但在错误的语境下
Sorry, I'm yelling at you. I like it. Bring it on. I'm getting very worked up by how Dwight eats. Well, now the meeting is underway in the conference room. Michael is perched on his chair, like a bird. 9 minutes, 36 seconds. How does Steve sit like this? I don't know. How does he do it? He just finds the most awkward ways to sit and stand. And it's so funny. Well, he apologizes for all of the men who didn't take this seriously. Creed still doesn't understand what the big deal is. But Michael explains no one likes being flashed. It's not just women. When Meredith flashed him during the Christmas party, he was sick. He hated it. Yeah. But listen, he also wants us to know that a penis in the right context is the most wonderful sight for a woman. But in the wrong
抱歉，我对你大喊大叫了。我喜欢这样。放马过来吧。德怀特吃东西的方式让我非常激动。好吧，现在会议在会议室开始了。迈克尔像一只鸟一样栖息在椅子上。9分36秒。史蒂夫怎么能这样坐？我不知道。他是怎么做到的？他总是能找到最别扭的坐姿和站姿。这太搞笑了。好吧，他为所有没有认真对待这件事的男士们道歉。克里德仍然不明白这有什么大不了的。但迈克尔解释说，没有人喜欢被暴露狂袭击。不仅仅是女性。当梅雷迪思在圣诞派对上向他暴露身体时，他生病了。他恨透了。是的。但是听着，他还想让我们知道，在正确的语境下，男性的阴茎对女性来说是最美妙的景象。但在错误的语境下
context, it's like a monster movie. I have a question for you. When Dwight goes alien, blah, and Michael's like, shut it, shut up. Was that improvised? Oh my God, I don't know. Do you want me to look it up? I do because I remember Rainn as Dwight messing around. And I just didn't know if that was him being an idiot. And it got to stay in. Well, let me see. How should I find this in this document? I'm thinking I should put in the word penis and see. Oh, there's so many. So many. Oh boy. I'm opening up some snacks. Your grandma would not have liked this word search right now. No. Oh, all right. Okay, I found it. So after Michael said that, Dwight was supposed to say Freddy Krueger. Okay, I remember this. I remember that Rainn kept doing these alts that he was kind
背景，就像一部怪物电影。我有一个问题要问你。当德怀特变成外星人，巴拉巴拉，然后迈克尔说，闭嘴，闭上嘴。那是即兴发挥吗？哦天哪，我不知道。你想让我查一下吗？我想，因为我记得雷恩扮演的德怀特在胡闹。我只是不知道那是他在当傻子。而且还被保留下来了。好吧，让我看看。我该怎么在这个文档里找到这个？我在想我是不是应该输入“阴茎”这个词然后看看。哦，有太多了。太多了。哦天哪。我在打开一些零食。你奶奶现在肯定不会喜欢这个字谜游戏的。不。哦，好吧。好吧，我找到了。所以迈克尔说完那句话后，德怀特本该说弗莱迪·克鲁格。好吧，我记得这个。我记得雷恩一直在做这些他当时临时编出来的替代台词。而那个外星人并不是写在剧本里的。我挺确定的，但我还是想看看。你是对的。这是一个随意的题外话。好吧。你有没有被人暴露过身体？好吧，我在纽约市待了很长时间，在街上看到过很多阴茎。但我坐过地铁，却从来没有直接被人暴露过。你呢？哦，我是说，听着，那些在听的女性，那些人就是变态。我的意思是，我确实被人暴露过。有一次，我在伦敦等地铁。我当时在读大学，正在进行海外交换学期。我和我的朋友站在那儿，有个老头。我是说他七十多岁了。就像，如果你在电影里看到这个，你会觉得，哦，这也太刻意了。他真的穿着一件卡其色风衣。他有70岁。哦。然后他打开风衣，完全赤身裸体，扭动着他老头的阴茎。我们当时就想，哦天哪。这对我来说太疯狂了，因为看起来就像卡通里走出来的一样。我当时想，这不可能是真的。老家伙，卡其色风衣，地铁里的暴露狂。拜托。你知道，暴露身体被认为是一种性侵犯。据统计，许多年轻和未成年女性，她们经历的某种第一次性侵犯就是暴露身体，是男人向她们暴露阴茎。这太可怕了。这他妈太可怕了。我当时很年轻。所以我只是“啊”了一声，然后多年以后，我被人暴露了身体，我大喊了一声，“别闹了”。但为什么我们必须应对这种事？我不知道。为什么女性必须应对这种事？就好像，我这一天做的事还不够多吗？我还得告诉你不要向我暴露身体。是的。我很忙。把阴茎从我眼前拿开。我很忙。我没时间理会那种破事。我没时间看你老头子的阴茎。阴茎。不，我没有。说真的。你知道我的意思吗？我奶奶会把我们关掉的，珍娜。这个播客。我觉得你奶奶在这件事上会站在我这边。哦，肯定的。我想让你奶奶和我一起去跟一些暴露狂谈谈。哦，她会让他们好看的。好吧，让我们看看。对不起，我扯远了，但我当时就在想，嘿，我被人暴露过身体。我想知道珍娜是不是也遇到过，大多数女性都遇到过。大多数女性都遇到过暴露狂。是的。这就是问题所在。是的。你知道吗，顺便说一句，我只想说，不请自来的阴茎照片短信就是现代的暴露身体。哦，是的。如果一个女人没有要求看你的阴茎，就不要发照片。是的。这并不难。是的。真的。这就好比，为什么非得说出来呢？哦，天哪。你把我惹火了。对不起。我只是突然意识到我从来没有收到过阴茎照片。什么？说实话，我从来没有收到过阴茎照片。我们老了。我们老了，但我们被人暴露过。我们被人暴露过，但年轻姑娘们会收到阴茎照片。好吧。我们刚才说到哪了？我们刚才说到迈克尔对社会很生气。他说问题在于媒体把女性描绘成苗条、高挑的女神，如果你环顾办公室，他们在现实生活中显然不是这样。是的。你知道，甚至最好看的那些人也是，他怎么说的？没那么瘦或者别的什么。
of making up in the moment. And that alien one was not one that was scripted. I was pretty sure, but I wanted to see. You were right. This is a random tangent. Okay. Have you ever been flashed? Well, I've spent a lot of time in New York City, and I've seen a lot of penises on the street. But I've been on the subway, but I've never been directly flashed. What about you? Oh, I mean, listen, women out there listening, they're just creepers. And I mean, I have been flashed. One, I was waiting for the tube in London. I was in college and doing a semester abroad. And my friend and I were standing there in this old man. I'm talking in his 70s. It was like, if you saw it in a movie, you'd be like, Oh, it's too on the nose. He literally had
珍娜，你当时是不是觉得，嘿，搞什么鬼？不，人们总是问我们这个问题，问我们是否被针对我们自己的笑话冒犯了。并没有，我不知道。是不是因为在喜剧中，你经常被要求进行自我贬低，或者你只是很有幽默感？我不知道。我觉得挺好笑的。是的。我的意思是，我也一样。我总是拿自己的体型开玩笑，你知道的。而且这也真的从来没有让人感觉针对个人。我不知道。这个笑话的意思是他说了一些他不该说的话，对吧？是的。好吧，卡伦告诉迈克尔他有厌女症，然后迈克尔说，谢谢。谢谢。是的。然后她说，不，我是说你很大男子主义。他说，不，我不是。我有厌女症。然后她说，哦天哪。接着女人们就开始
on a khaki trench coat. He was 70. Oh. And he opened up his trench coat and was totally naked and wiggled around his old man penis. And we were like, Oh my God. It was so crazy to me because it looked like something out of a cartoon. I was like, this can't be real. Old dude, khaki coat, flasher in a subway. Come on. You know, flashing is considered a sexual assault. And statistically, many young and underage women, that is their sort of first experience with a sexual assault is flashing is men flashing their penises. And it's horrible. It's freaking horrible. I was young. So I just went, Ah, and then years later, I was flashed and I literally yelled, knock it off. But why do we have to deal with that? I don't know. Why do women have to deal with that? Like, I don't have enough
真正地数落他了。菲利斯说，迈克尔，当我把头发剪短时，你说我看起来像个女同性恋。安吉拉说，对啊。而且如果我们不高兴，你总觉得我们处于经期。但那是因为他需要知道他是否该把你们当回事。不，有很多问题。有很多问题。好吧，卡伦和安吉拉想回去工作，但迈克尔说他知道问题出在哪里。问题在于他们处于一个过于阳刚的环境中，无法真正建立感情和得到治愈。他得带她们去商场。是的。他需要把女性带到一个能让她们得到治愈的地方。那就是购物中心。是的。我们看到了一系列访谈镜头。
to do in my day. I also have to tell you not to flash me. Yeah. I'm busy. Penis out of my face. I'm busy. I don't have time for that shit. I don't have time for your old man penis. Penis. No, I don't. For reals. You know what I mean? My grandmother would have turned us off, Jenna. This podcast. I feel like your grandma would be on my side on this one. Oh, for sure. I'd like your grandma and I to go around and talk to some flashers. Oh, she would let them have it. Well, let's see. Sorry, I got us off on a tangent, but I was just like, Hey, I've been flashed. I wonder if Jenna has most women. Most women have been flashed. Yeah. That's the problem. Yeah. And you know what, by the way, I just want to say the unsolicited dick
卡伦，她仍然觉得去商场这个想法很侮辱人，但她有一些东西要退货。我有一个访谈镜头，我说商场简直太糟糕了，太羞辱人了。那里只有一家又一家卖那些可怕衣服的店，人们大惊小怪地看着一个成年人在青少年区购物。这个访谈镜头的最后一句台词是我即兴发挥的。真的吗？是的。我说的。我说，有些成年人个子比较娇小，可能需要穿10号童装。大姐，我和你去过塔吉特百货购物。是的。你在青少年区购物。我确实买。我在儿童区购物。而且很长一段时间里，我都穿10号童装。我记得你当时根本找不到一条裤子上没有
pick text is the modern day flashing. Oh, yes. If a woman doesn't ask to see your dick, don't send a pick. Yeah. It's not difficult. Yeah. Truly. Truly. It's like, why does it need to be said? Oh, my God. You got me all amped up. I'm sorry. I just am realizing I've never gotten a dick pick. What? Honestly, I've never gotten a dick pick. We're old. We're old, but we've been flashed. We've been flashed, but young ladies get dick picks. Okay. Where were we? Where we are is that Michael is angry at society. He says that the problem is that the media portrays women as being skinny, tall goddesses, which if you look around the office, they clearly are not in real life. Yeah. You know, even the prettiest ones are, what does he say? Not that thin or something.
彩虹贴花的牛仔裤。是的。你所有的衣服。我所有的衣服上面都有蝴蝶什么的。我不再穿10号童装了。好吧，那就这样吧。谢谢大流行带来的这一切。是的。谢谢隔离期间胖了15磅。但我现在穿14号童装。哦，原来如此。隔离期间胖15磅就像是一件真事。随着假期的临近，我有点担心，因为我已经，我已经在假期服装的尺寸上开始超重了。我不知道，假期过后会发生什么？我正穿着我以前称之为宽松牛仔裤的裤子。它们紧得要命。就像我得吸着肚子才能扣上纽扣一样。我们该怎么办？我不知道。当派对和圣诞饼干开始的时候，我们该怎么办？
Jenna, were you just like, Hey, what the heck? No, people ask us that all the time if we were personally offended by jokes at our expense. And no, I don't know. Is it just because in comedy, you're so often asked to be self deprecating or you just have a good sense of humor? I don't know. I thought it was funny. Yeah. I mean, same with me. I'm always like some size joke, you know. And it also just never really felt personal. I don't know. The joke is that he's saying something he shouldn't say, right? Yeah. Well, Karen tells Michael he's being misogynistic and Michael is like, Thank you. Thank you. Yes. And she's like, No, I'm saying you're being sexist. He's like, No, I'm not. I'm being misogynistic. And she's like, Oh my God. And then the women just start
感恩节会把我逼到极限的。我不知道会发生什么。好吧。所以帕姆现在完成了她画的暴露狂素描，并把它交给了德怀特。是的。他激动极了。她说，听着，菲利斯看得很清楚。这很准确。德怀特开始复印这份传单，上面写着：这个人是个变态。而照片非常明显就是没戴眼镜、留着胡子的德怀特。大姐，我保留了那一周的一份传单，我有它。我有原件，雷恩作为德怀特举着的那些原件之一。我很喜欢它。这让我发笑。我有它在我的剪贴簿里，本，说到这个，我开始做剪贴簿了。
to really call him out. Phyllis is like, Michael, when I got my haircut short, you said I look like a lesbian. And Angela's like, Yeah. And you always think we're on our periods if we get upset. But that's because he needs to know if he should take you seriously or not. No, there's a lot of issues. There's a lot of issues. Well, Karen and Angela want to get back to work, but Michael says he knows what the problem is. The problem is they're in too masculine of an environment to really bond and heal. He needs to take them to the mall. Yeah. He needs to take the women to a place where they can heal. And that's the shopping mall. Yes. We see a series of talking heads.
我在你的Instagram快拍上看到了，你让你的孩子们去做那个。他们非常兴奋。他们很喜欢。这让我很高兴。我觉得这是个好主意。好吧，听着，如果你看这张海报，上面有一个电话号码，一个打击暴露狂特别行动组的1-800热线电话。这是一个真实的电话号码。是的。在这集之后，你可以拨打这个电话，你会听到德怀特留下的语音留言。我知道这段留言说的是什么。我喜欢这个。读出来，珍娜。你已接通德怀特·K·施鲁特，拉克瓦纳县
Karen, she still thinks all of this idea of going to the malls insulting, but she had some items to return. I have a talking head that I say that malls are just awful and humiliating. They're just store after store of these horrible cells, people making a big fuss out of an adult shopping in a junior section. And I improvised the last line of this talking head. You did? I did. I did. I said, there are petite adults who are sort of smaller who need to wear maybe a kid size 10. Lady, I've been to Target with you and gone shopping. Yeah. And you shop in the junior section. I do. I shop in the kids section. And for a long time, I was a kid size 10. I remember you couldn't find a pair of jeans that didn't have like
打击暴露狂特别行动组指挥官兼邓德米夫林地区经理。如果你有能抓获和（或）阉割这个变态的线索，请按1。如果这就是那个暴露狂，我们谈谈吧。你现在需要一个朋友，而我能帮到你。只要告诉我你想在哪里见面，我保证帮你解决你需要的一切。谢谢，祝你度过愉快的一天。哦，如果你是在询问我们的纸制品并想要一份产品目录，请按2。最后，如果除了暴露狂之外的任何人对一辆超级带劲的1985年栗色火鸟（Firebird）跑车感兴趣的话，我可以被说服把它卖掉。这事儿也请按1。真的有人打过这个电话。很多人都打过这个电话。这里有一个有趣的琐事，
a rainbow applique on the pocket. Yeah. All your clothes. All my clothes had a butterfly or something on it. I am no longer a kid size 10. So well, there you go. Thank you, pandemic for that. Yeah. Thank you, quarantine 15. But I am a kid size 14. Oh, I see. The quarantine 15 is like a real thing. And as the holidays approach, I am concerned because I've already, I am already tipping the scales into my holiday clothes. I don't, what is going to happen after the holidays? I am in what I used to call my baggy jeans. And they're like so tight. Like I had to suck into button them. What are we going to do? I don't know. What are we going to do when the pies and Christmas cookies start?
小花絮。那是万斯冷气公司（Vance Refrigeration）的同一个电话号码。哦，是的。是的。当我们看到万斯冷气公司的电话号码时。是的。好吧，听着，大姐，在我们出发去商场之前，也许我们该休息一下。我们休息一下吧，因为接下来我们要上梅丽尔的货车了，我们得，我们需要讨论一下。是的。好吧，我们回来了，所有的女士们都和迈克尔一起坐着梅丽尔那辆非常棒的货车前往商场。是的，她在开车，但同时还在吃薯片和乱扔垃圾。我希望你们都知道，我们后面跟着一辆货车，他们的任务就是捡起
Thanksgiving is going to push me over. I don't know what is going to happen. Okay. So Pam has now finished her sketch of the flasher and hands it over to Dwight. Yes. And he is thrilled. She's like, listen, Phyllis got a good look. This is accurate. Dwight starts making copies of this flyer, which reads, this man is a pervert. And the picture is very clearly Dwight with no glasses and a mustache. Lady, I saved one of these flyers from that week and I have it. I have the original, one of the original ones that rain is holding up as Dwight. And I love it. It makes me laugh. I have it in my scrapbook, Ben, speaking of, I've started scrapbooking.
掉出来的袋子。袋子会掉出车外，他们得把袋子捡起来。所以我们实际上并没有乱扔垃圾。这太不可思议了。是的。我们有一个来自妮基·劳伦斯的关于货车的粉丝提问。你们是怎么决定在梅丽尔的货车里的座位顺序的？这是计划好的，还是随便坐的？嗯，我知道我坐在前排座位上，因为我晕车，我知道他们是这样计划的，但我看了剧本，剧本上是这样写这辆货车的。好吧。上面写着，货车里到处都是外卖餐盒，仪表盘上亮着所有能想象到的警告灯。迈克尔坐在中间一排的中间座位上，夹在凯利和菲利斯之间。卡伦和安吉拉在最后一排。迈克尔看着姑娘们聊天，就像简·古道尔在观察黑猩猩一样。那是，那是我们货车座位的剧本导演指令。所以这是计划好的。但是大姐，当我读到这段时，你在剧集中是看不到的，但你还记得那辆货车里面有多脏吗？珍娜，太疯狂了。道具部门全力以赴。你根本看不到地板。他们往那辆货车里扔了那么多东西。看起来真的就像有人在里面住了好几年一样。到处都是外卖餐盒。还有一些半吃完的食物，或者被做成半吃完样子的食物。坐在我旁边座位上的是一块吃了一半的巧克力曲巧克芯片饼干，就在我旁边的座位上。当我们上车时，我们踩上去，脚踝会在所有这些奇怪的东西上扭到。各种衣物，
I saw on your Instagram stories, you put your kids to work on that. They were very excited. They loved it. It made me happy. I think it's a great idea. Well, listen, if you look on this poster, there is a phone number, a 1-800 number for the anti-flashing task force. This was a real phone number. Yes. And after the episode, you could call it and you would get a message from Dwight. And I have what the message said. I love this. Read it, Jenna. You have reached Dwight K. Schrute, commander of the Lackawanna County,
比如一件，像一件破旧的衣服，像旧手机，简直能想象到的一切。看起来就像有人把垃圾桶倒在了地板上。好吧，他们做的另一件事，我不知道你还记不记得，安吉，作为一个笑话，他们觉得如果把所有这些空气清新剂都放在她车的前面会非常搞笑。所以梅丽尔不会清理她的车，她只会再加一个空气清新剂，它们从后视镜上悬挂下来。到处都是仪表盘上。是的，车前面到处都是。只有凯和我坐的前面，这些空气清新剂的气味让我们感到恶心。你当时一直在头痛，你一直说，天哪，伙计们，我一直在
anti-flashing task force and regional manager of Dunder Mifflin. If you have information leading to the capture and or castration of this pervert, press one. If this is the flasher, let's talk. You need a friend right now and I can help you. Just tell me where you want to meet and I promise to help you with whatever it is you need. Thank you and have a nice day. Oh, and if you are inquiring about any of our paper products and would like a catalog, please press two. Finally, if anyone not the flasher is interested in a kick-ass 1985 maroon firebird, I could be persuaded to sell mine. Please press one for that too. And people called it. A lot of people called that number. Here's an interesting trivia,
头痛，你知道的，在我们坐货车拍戏的时候。我坐在最后面，旁边是吃了一半的食物。我闻不到空气清新剂的味道。我记得突然有那么一刻，你和凯异口同声地说，哦天哪，是这些空气清新剂。这里大概有15个。事情是这样的，你甚至看不到它们。所以他们就想，哦，我们在镜头里甚至看不到那些。我们可以直接把它们拿掉。所以他们拿掉了，然后我们就没事了。真遗憾，你没能看到剧组为了让那辆货车内部看起来那么破旧所付出的辛苦工作。是的，那是一件艺术品。珍娜，DVD评论里有一件事是关于梅丽尔吃薯片的那个场景的，就像她直接把薯片从袋子里倒在
tidbit. That is the same phone number as Vance refrigeration. Oh, yes. Yes. When we've seen the Vance refrigeration phone number. Yep. Well, listen, lady, before we head out to the mall, maybe we should take a break. Let's take a break because then we're getting into Meredith's van and we're going to need to, we're going to need to talk about it. Yeah. Okay, we are back and all the ladies are off to the mall with Michael in Meredith's really fantastic van. Yeah, she's driving, but also eating potato chips and littering. I do want you all to know that we had a van following behind us and their job was to pick up
脸上，然后把袋子扔掉。在DVD评论中，你提到你一直在笑，一直在笑，一直在笑。你根本无法保持严肃的表情。他们实际上使用了你在货车里另一个时刻的不同反应镜头，因为他们从来没有拍到你干净的表情。我可能也很嫉妒，因为我真的很喜欢那些酸奶油洋葱味的薯片。你也喜欢酸奶油洋葱味。你和我的女儿，伊莎贝尔很喜欢。我也喜欢。我不能把它们放在家里。那就会变成切达兔子饼干的重演了。哦，不。隔离期间胖15磅。
the bag. It would go out the car and they had to pick up the bag. So we in fact did not litter. That is incredible. Yeah. We had a fan question about the van from Nikki Lawrence. How did they decide the order in which you all sat in Meredith's van? Was it planned out or did you just sit wherever? Well, I know that I sat in the front seat because I get carsick and I know that they planned it that way, but I went to the script and here is what it said about the van. Okay. It said, the van is strewn with takeout containers and the dashboard is lit with every warning light imaginable. Michael sits in the middle seat of the middle row between Kelly and Phyllis. Karen and Angela are in the back row. Michael watches the girls talk as if he's
是的，我知道。所以现在我们回到了邓德米夫林，这是一个非常古怪的小情节，凯文走到吉姆面前说，你想和我一起去女厕所吗？我觉得这太有趣了，因为我真的很相信这种好奇心，就像，那边的那边是什么样的？你知道吗？我的意思是，我去过男厕所，就像，太恶心了。恶心。太Gross了。比如，我大约一年前去过星巴克之类的地方，女厕所排着长队，然后我女儿真的，真的非常想上厕所
Jane Goodall observing apes. That is, that was the script direction for our van placement. So it was planned. But lady, when I read this, you can't see it in the episode, but do you remember how filthy the inside of that van was? Jenna, it was so crazy. The props department went all out. You could not see the floorboard. That's how much stuff they threw into that van. It literally looked like someone had lived in there for years. There were takeout containers. There were like food items that had been half eaten or made to look half eaten. Sitting next to me in the seat was a half eaten chocolate chip cookie on, on the seat next to me. And when we would get in, we would step and like kind of turn our ankles on all these weird things. Pieces of clothing,
而男厕所里没有人。所以我就想，听着，我们快去快回，你进男厕所去，里面到底发生什么了？我想说的另一件事是，你知道，有很多带着女儿的父亲，他们积极地抚养孩子，他们去各种地方，他们的孩子需要上厕所。顺便说一句，他们的小男孩也需要坐着上厕所。我们能保持厕所清洁吗，伙计们？我们能把它们弄得干净一点，这样爸爸们就可以带孩子去上厕所，而且不会完全恶心吗？珍娜只要求两件事，伙计们。不要发阴茎照片。
like a, like a broken, like old phone, like just everything you could imagine. It looked like someone dumped a trash can in the floorboard. Well, another thing they did, and I don't know if you remember this, Ange, but as a joke, they thought it would be really funny if they put all of these air fresheners in the front of her car. So like Meredith wouldn't clean out her car, she would just add another air freshener and they were dangling from the rear view mirror. They were all over the dashboard. Yes, they were all over the front of the car. Just the front where Kate and I were sitting and the fumes from these air fresheners were making us sick. You were getting a headache and you kept being like, gosh, guys, I keep getting
不，是不请自来的。如果一个女人要求你发阴茎照片，就把她打发走。开火吧。去吧。开火吧。开火吧。我不知道为什么这让我发笑。但是，是的，把你们的马桶收拾干净。所以，是的，凯文很好奇。他想进女厕所，他走进去，然后他说，哦天哪，你得来看看这个。里面有沙发，有香包，
a headache, you know, while we were filming in the van. I was in the way back with half eaten food. I couldn't smell the air fresheners. I remember there was all of a sudden this moment where you and Kate were like, oh my God, it's these air fresheners. There's like 15 of them. And here's the thing, you couldn't even see them. So they were like, oh, we don't even see those in the shot. We can just take those out. So they took them out and then we were fine. It's too bad you couldn't see the hard work that the crew did to make that van look so junky inside. Yeah, it was, it was a work of art. Jenna, there's one thing in the DVD commentary about the scene where Meredith is eating the potato chips, like just she just dumps them on
有蜡烛，还有一盏漂亮的台灯，你知道的，有杂志。你怪我们吗？这是我们远离迈克尔的唯一避难所。我们不得不在这个办公室里这么做。这是他唯一不能来跟我们说话的地方。所以我们创造了一个，我相信是一个避难所。哦，是的。好吧，我得告诉你，这个浴室，女浴室的布景，这是一个不能使用的浴室。当我们不用的时候，所有的水槽和马桶实际上都不能用。我一直为此感到沮丧，顺便说一句。
her face from the bag and throws the bag out. In the DVD commentary, you said you kept laughing and laughing and laughing. You couldn't keep a straight face. And they actually used a different reaction shot of you from a different moment in the van because they never got a clean one of you. I was probably jealous too because I really like those sour cream and onion chips. You too love sour cream and onion. You and my daughter, Isabel loves them. I do too. I can't keep them in the house. It'll just be cheddar bunnies all over again. Oh no. Quarantine 15.
因为它们离我们的布景太方便了，但它们不是真的。真正的浴室要远得多，我总是希望我们的假马桶和水槽能用。你知道，他们曾经在马桶上贴标语，警告访客它们是假的，没有接通任何管道。是的，我觉得这些标语是因为有人不知道才制作的。他们不得不处理那一刻。他们确实处理了。
Yeah, I know. So now we're back at Dunder Mifflin and this is such a quirky little storyline where Kevin comes up to Jim and says, would you like to join me in the women's bathroom? I thought this was so funny because I just so believe this curiosity of like, what's it like on the other side over there? You know? I mean, I've been in a men's room and like, it's disgusting. Disgusting. So gross. Like, I've been like somewhere like a Starbucks like a year ago or so and there's a line for the women's room and like, my daughter really, really had to go
哦，真恶心。没错，有个访客用了我们的假马桶。你能想象吗，如果你是办公室的超级粉丝，你得以参观片场进行游览，你欣喜若狂，看到所有你喜欢的角色你都太高兴了，而你就是那个在片场的假马桶里拉了一堆屎的访客。那个人是谁？那个人自己心里清楚。这就是为什么我们不得不制作标语并用胶带把马桶封起来。哦，好吧，对不起。好吧，我还想说，在这个情节之前，浴室看起来并不是这样的。
and there was no one in the men's room. So I was like, listen, we'll just go quickly and you go in the men's room and it's like, what is going on in there? Another thing I'd like to say is that, you know, there are a lot of fathers with daughters and they are actively parenting their children and they go places and their kids need to use the bathroom. And by the way, their little boys need to sit down too. Can we keep our bathrooms clean, guys? Can we keep them a little cleaner so that dads can take their kids to the bathroom and it's not totally disgusting? Jenna is just asking two things, guys. No dick pics.
他们不得不搭建这个小布景。他们确实搭了。我的意思是，几乎这些假浴室真的很小，当它们不被用作浴室时，就是储藏室。它们就像衣橱一样。是的，剧组会把他们的灯架和灯光之类的东西放在那些浴室门后面。好吧，他们在浴室里的这个场景，他们只是在随便闲聊，吉姆说他和卡伦在一起六个月纪念日要出去吃晚餐。
No, it's solicited. If a lady asks for your dick pic, send her away. Fire away. Go for it. Fire away. Fire away. I don't know why that's making me laugh. But yeah, and keep your toilets tidy. So yes, Kevin is curious. He wants to go in the women's room and he goes in and he's like, oh my God, you got to see this. There's like a sofa, there's potpourri,
我有一个问题。我们庆祝恋爱六个月纪念日吗？我们在做那件事吗？我想如果事情进展不顺利的话，你就会庆祝。这就是我想说的。是的。当你需要庆祝某些事情因为进展艰难时，你就会纪念你们恋爱六个月的纪念日。是的，因为你会觉得，我们坚持了六个月，这对她意义重大。
there's candles, there's like a nice lamp, you know, magazines. Do you blame us? This is our only sanctuary away from Michael. We've had to do this in this office. It's the one place he cannot come speak to us. So we've created, I believe, a sanctuary. Oh yeah. Well, I have to tell you, this bathroom, the women's bathroom set, this is a non-working bathroom. None of the sinks and toilets actually worked when we weren't using them. I was always bummed about that, by the way.
所以让我们庆祝一下吧。我也有同样的看法。我在这个场景里笑得前仰后合，因为瑞恩显然不知道什么是香包。他是打算吃掉它吗？他在玩它。他在那里坐立不安。而且这也挺尴尬的。他给卡伦发了封邮件，吉姆就说，对啊，她读给我听了。
Because they were so conveniently located to our set, but they weren't real. The actual bathrooms were much further away, and I always wished our fake toilets and sinks worked. You know, they used to put signs on the toilets, warning visitors that they were fake and not hooked up to any plumbing. Yes, and I feel like those signs were made because someone didn't know. They had to deal with that moment. They did.
这太尴尬了，而且拍得太好了。但我还是忍不住看着B.J.摆弄那个香包。我同意。好吧，回到商场，梅丽尔正在把货车停好，她直接撞上了旁边的一辆车。珍娜，在DVD评论中，他们说我们真的那样做了。我们真的，真的刮擦了一辆真正的车。不，不是我们不车。不，那是我们的车。
Oh, yuck. That's true, a visitor used our fake toilet. Can you imagine if you're a big fan of the office, and you get to come to set and get a tour, and you're just giddy, you're so happy to see all these characters that you love, and you're the visitor that took a dump in the fake toilet on set. Who was that person? That person knows who they are. And that's why we had to make signs and tape up the toilets. Oh, okay, sorry. Well, also, I want to say that the bathroom didn't look like this before this episode.
但尽管如此，他们本来打算看看是否能作弊，让它看起来很挤。但那个镜头你没法作弊。然后加个音效什么的。是的。他们本来打算加个音效，看看我们是不是可以作弊。但你做不到。你看得太清楚了。所以他们只能让凯真的那样做。
They had to build this little set. They did. I mean, pretty much these fake bathrooms were really small, and when they weren't being used, they were storage. They were like closets. Yeah, the crew would keep like their stands and lights and things behind those bathroom doors. Well, this scene that they have in the bathroom, they're kind of just chit-chatting, and Jim says that he's going out to dinner for his six-month anniversary with Karen.
凯·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery），没有特技司机，把那辆货车卡进去并刮擦了那辆车。然后我们不得不赔偿损失。但那是我们的车。那是一辆道具车，作为我们的一种道具车。好吧，当我们进入商场时，我们在美食广场。你还记得吗，大姐，当时大概早上7点。是的。而且我，天色还很早。
And I have a question. Do we celebrate our six-month anniversary of dating? Are we doing that? I think you do if things aren't going well. That's what I was going to say. Yeah. You mark the occasion of your six-month dating anniversary when you need something to celebrate because it's been difficult. Yeah, because you're like, we made it six months, and this will mean a lot to her.
我刚刚看了这个场景。你谈到瑞恩玩香包。我当时看的时候印象深刻，拉什达竟然能在早上7点吃下那些薯片。我当时想，你真行。我记得当时真的很希望有苏打水。就像我当时想的那样，哦，我愿意用任何东西换一杯可口可乐之类的东西，因为时间太早了。但那些杯子里只有水。然后我就想，哦，该死。
So let's celebrate it. I had that same thought. I was cracking up in the scene because Ryan clearly doesn't know what potpourri is. Is he going to eat it? He's playing with it. He's fidgeting. And it's also awkward. He sent Karen this email, and Jim's like, yeah, she read it to me.
我能来点咖啡因就好了。我记得我很嫉妒明迪的辛纳本（Cinnabon）肉桂卷。是的。我一直在看《电城报》（The Electric City），那是一份真正的斯克兰顿报纸。是的。好吧，我还想指出的是，在这个场景中，迈克尔说，女士们，让我们随便聊聊你们脑子里的任何事吧。然后我数了一下。
It's so cringy and just so well done. But I couldn't help but watch B.J. playing with that potpourri. I agree. Well, back at the mall, Meredith is parking the van, and she is just crashing into a car next to her. Jenna, in the DVD commentary, they said we really did that. We really, really scraped up an actual car. No, not one that we didn't own. No, we owned it.
有15秒钟的沉默。我喜欢那个。我喜欢我们的节目这样做。我知道。他打破沉默的方式是问什么是子宫颈抹片检查（pap smear）。然后还有，到底是smear还是smear，作为一个年轻女性成长的时候？我有点不清楚到底是smear还是smear。我完全不知道。
But still, they were going to see if they could cheat it, where it looked really tight. But you can't cheat that shot. And just put in a sound effect or something. Yes. They were going to put in a sound effect and see if maybe we could just cheat. But you couldn't. You could see it too clearly. So they just let Kate actually do that.
是smear。子宫颈抹片检查（Pap smear）。Pap smear。是的。只是如果，如果这还在困扰着其他任何人，它不是像百吉饼上的奶油干酪那样抹（smear）。是的。他们把它涂抹上去（smear it）。
Kate Flannery, there was no stunt driver, wedged that van and scraped up that car. And then we had to pay for the damages. But it was our car. It was like a picture car as our sort of prop car. Well, when we get into the mall, we're up in the food court. And you remember, lady, it was like 7 a.m. Yeah. And I, it was so early.
好吧。他们做完抹片检查之后。没错。帕姆把话题转到了凯利和瑞恩身上，但那并没有什么进展。然后迈克尔开始问他们关于角色扮演的事。这就是他，我猜，清楚地表明他和简确实会玩角色扮演，他是女学生，但显然菲利斯也是。菲利斯说，对啊，这挺有意思的。
And I just watched this scene. You talk about Ryan playing with the potpourri. And I was just watching this being so impressed that Rashida committed to eating those chips at 7 a.m. I was like, you go. I remember really wishing we had soda. Like I was like, oh, I'd give anything for a Coca-Cola or something because it was so early. But those cups just had water in them. And I was like, oh, dang it.
菲利斯非常，她确实，她绝对不反对这个想法。不，她是。然而，安吉拉则是一副“我要离开这儿了。我要去娃娃店”的态度。是的。她就像，我不需要坐在这里听迈克尔谈论他和简的性生活。我走了。是的。
I could use some caffeine. I remember being very jealous of Mindy's Cinnabon. Yes. And I'm just reading The Electric City the whole time, which is an actual Scranton newspaper. Yes. Well, I also want to note that in this scene, Michael says, ladies, let's dish about anything on your mind. And then I counted.
现在，安吉拉，接下来有一个大场面，然后你不在里面。你在干什么？你只是回你的房车了吗？我依稀记得我坐在卖蝴蝶饼（pretzel）的地方，也就是安蒂安妮（Auntie Anne's）那样的蝴蝶饼店旁边。我以为那是韦策尔蝴蝶饼（Wetzel's Pretzels）。是的。那是安蒂安妮吗？是其中之一吧。
There is a 15 second moment of silence. I love that. I love when our show does that. I know. And he breaks the silence by asking what a pap smear is. And then also, is it smear growing up as a young woman? It was a little unclear to me if it was smear or smear. I had no idea.
好吧，在这个场景中，我们让迈克尔列出他和简在一起的利弊清单。他和简在一起，其中一个缺点是：和她在一起我并不快乐。然后我们，我们都算是帮他听到了这一点，对吧？是的。或者像迈克尔，我觉得你应该和简分手。他不确定。菲利斯就说，别想了。你想怎么做？
It's smear. Pap smear. Pap smear. Yeah. Just if, and if this has been haunting anyone else, it is not smear like the cream cheese on a bagel. Yeah. They smear it.
迈克尔说，我想和简分手。我想和简分手。是的。是的。我的意思是，我觉得这是菲利斯一个非常棒的小时刻。我也做过这样的事，珍娜。难道你没有，难道你没有过那种时刻，你会觉得，你对某事有很多感受，你正试图弄清楚它们。然后你就觉得，好吧，安静一下我的脑子。
Okay. After they pap it. That's right. Pam changes the subject to Kelly and Ryan, but that doesn't really go anywhere. And then Michael starts asking them about role play. And this is when he, I guess, it becomes clear that he and Jan do role play where he is the school girl, but also apparently so does Phyllis. Phyllis is like, yeah, it can be fun.
这让我有什么感觉？如果我在做决定时遇到困难，无论是一件大事还是一件小事。我会拿出一枚硬币，我们把它当作一件小事吧。比方说，我想买这张新沙发。好吧。但我拿不定主意。好吧。所以正面是买沙发，反面是不买沙发。我并不是让硬币来决定，但我做的是我把它抛了。
Phyllis is very, she is, she's certainly not disapproving of the idea. No, she's. Angela, however, is like, I'm out of here. I'm going to the doll store. Yeah. She's like, I don't need to sit here and listen to Michael talk about his sex life with Jan. I'm out. Yeah.
是的。然后我注意我对结果的反应。因为通常你其实是在意的，是或不是。所以如果我抛了硬币，结果是不买沙发，而我感到如释重负，那么我就有了答案。但如果它说不，不要买沙发，而我很失望，心想，哦，三局两胜，这意味着我想买沙发。对吧？这说得通吗？
Now, Angela, there is a big scene coming up now, and then you're not in it. What were you doing? Were you just back in your trailer? I kind of remember sitting by the pretzel place, the Auntie Ann's, like pretzel place. I thought it was a Wetzel's pretzel. Yes. Is it an Auntie Ann's? It's one of those.
这确实说得通。我觉得我总是知道。我基本上总是很清楚自己对某事的感受。我不需要去剖析我对它的感受。这对我来说非常清晰。而且你做决定也很容易。是的。是的，即使是对分手和恋爱关系也是如此。
Well, in this scene, we asked Michael to make a list of pros and cons for why he is with Jan. He is with Jan, and one of his cons is I'm not happy when I'm with her. And we, we all kind of like help him hear that, right? Yeah. Or like Michael, I think you should break up with Jan. And he's not sure. And Phyllis is like, no thinking. What do you want to do?
好吧，关于恋爱关系是这样的。有时候你心里明白，但由于种种后果，你需要花一段时间才能大声说出来。没错。但我认为你心里一直都是知道的。好吧，我觉得女人们确实帮迈克尔明白了这一点，他非常兴奋，为了感谢她们的帮助，他要给她们每人买一件维多利亚的秘密（Victoria's Secret）的商品。这就是我们都想要的。是的。
And Michael says, I want to break up with Jan. I want to break up with Jan. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I feel like this is like a great little moment that Phyllis has. And I've done stuff like this, Jan. Haven't you, haven't you like had a moment where you're like, you have a lot of feelings about something and you're trying to make sense of them. And you just are like, okay, quiet my mind.
然后有一个访谈镜头，这一集的编剧李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）说，这是他为史蒂夫写的最喜欢的桥段之一，因为史蒂夫的演绎实在是太棒了。就是他说的那句，大多数男人都想要他们的女人穿着高跟鞋、露出乳沟、穿着暴露的小衣服。我显然是在意译，但他认为女人最好看起来一丝不挂。他只是说，当他听到史蒂夫说出那个访谈镜头的结尾时，他演得太到位了。就像，就像体操运动员完美落地一样。完全是这样。
How does this make me feel? If I'm having a hard time making a decision, it could be a big thing or a small thing. I'll get out a coin and let's make it a small thing. Let's be like, I want to buy this new couch. Okay. But I can't decide. Okay. So heads is buy the couch and tails is don't buy the couch. I don't let the coin decide, but what I do is I flip it.
好吧，珍娜，这里有一件小事。这一集有删减片段，其中有一些真的很棒。但有一个我发现有点好奇且有趣的是，除了帕姆和安吉拉外，所有的女性都进了维多利亚的秘密。她们俩留在商场外面，有一个节拍是你和我互相看着，我们并没有真正说什么，我们就像，好吧，然后我们俩都走了进去。好吧，这非常有趣，因为我们有一个粉丝捕捉到的彩蛋。哦。
Yeah. And then I note my reaction to the answer. Because usually you kind of do care, yes or no. So if I flip it and it says no, don't buy the couch and I feel relieved, then I have my answer. But if it says no, don't buy the couch and I'm disappointed and I'm like, oh, two out of three, that means I want to buy the couch. Right. Did that make sense?
来自索菲亚·李（Sophia Lee），这是其中一个时刻，安吉，在20分钟10秒的时候，你和我远远地背景里出现在史蒂夫的访谈镜头里，我们正一起走过维多利亚的秘密。我觉得我们当时不知道自己在镜头里，我们只是在购物。我们只是在背景里随便聊聊天。完全符合。我们要不要回到邓德米夫林的女士休息室？
It does make sense. I feel like I always know. I always know pretty much how I feel about something in the moment. I don't have to like break down how I feel about it. It's very clear to me. And it's easy for you to make decisions. Yes. Yes, even with breakups and relationships.
是的，我有一个我在这集里最喜欢的台词，是托比说的，保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）演得绝了。是的。凯文说，伙计们，我们应该多聚聚。这太棒了。然后托比说，我觉得我们聚的时间已经够久了。是的。太棒了。
Well, here's the thing about relationships. Sometimes you know, but it takes you a while before you can say it out loud because of the ramifications. Right. But I think you always know. Well, I think the women really help Michael know and he is very excited and to thank them for helping him, he's going to buy each one of them an item from Victoria's Secret. It's what we all wanted. Yeah.
是的。然后在这个20分35秒的时候，我们有一个重大的老旧科技警报。当克里德拿着一个随身听进入浴室时。拿着一个黄色的防水随身听。你还记得那些吗？我有一个。我有一个。
And then there is a talking head that Lee Eisenberg, the writer of this episode said, is one of his favorite things he got to write for Steve because Steve's delivery is so great. It's the one where he says, most guys want their women and high heels with cleavage and wearing skimpy little outfits. I'm paraphrasing obviously, but that he thinks a woman looks best absolutely naked. He just said when he heard Steve deliver the end of that talking head, he so nailed it. It was like, it was like a gymnast sticking the landing. Yeah, totally.
我有一个。它们是最好的。不过你还记得那些灰色的小按钮会弹出来吗？是的。是的。是的。你得把它塞回去。但这挺有意思的。
Well, Jenna, here's one quick thing. There are deleted scenes for this episode and there's some really great ones. But one that I found sort of curious and fun is that all the women go into the Victoria's Secrets except for Pam and Angela. They hang back outside in the mall and there's a beat where you and I look at each other and we don't really say anything and we're like, I guess, and then we both walk in. Well, that's very interesting because we had a fan catch. Oh.
为什么我们需要一个防水随身听？好吧，这个想法是你在锻炼的时候会出很多汗。但我的意思是，真的吗？好吧。好吧，我猜也是，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）告诉我，当克里德拿着那个随身听走进浴室，发现里面还有别人时，他显得非常震惊和惊恐，这会让所有人都笑喷。他们要拍好那一幕真的，真的很难，
From Sophia Lee and this is one of those moments, Ange, at 20 minutes, 10 seconds, you and I are way back in the background of Steve's talking head and we're just walking together through Victoria's Secret. I feel like we didn't know we were on camera and we're just shopping. We were just sort of being chatty in the background. Totally. That tracks. Should we go back to the Ladies' Lounge at Denner Mifflin?
就是让克里德进房间。他们就是让克里德进不去。我也很喜欢克里德的访谈镜头，因为他在做访谈镜头的时候还在听音乐。所以他有点像是在他听的音乐声中大喊大叫。是的。而且我觉得克里德跑去女厕所拉大号非常符合他的人设。你知道那种人，珍娜。
Yes, and I have one of my favorite lines from this episode and it's Toby and Paul Lieberstein totally crushes it. Yes. Kevin's like, we should do this more often, guys. This is great. And Toby goes, I think we hang out an appropriate amount of time. Yeah. It's so good.
你知道那种人。我们有过室友。那种跑去你的浴室而不是他们自己的浴室拉大号的室友。那就是克里德。好吧，现在，安吉，我们回到商场。安吉拉和迈克尔坐在一起。我太喜欢这个场景了。迈克尔极力想让安吉拉挑一件他能买给她的东西。
Yeah. It's so good. And then at 20 minutes, 35 seconds, we have a major old tech alert. When Creed enters the bathroom with a Walkman. With a yellow waterproof Walkman. Do you remember those? I owned one. I had one.
他有一句台词说，我能给你买点内衣吗？是的。所以你们知道，史蒂夫想让我笑场。他百分之百是在捉弄我。而且图克·盖茨（Tucker Gates）、李和吉恩给我下了非常严格的指示，他们真的不希望安吉拉顺着他的话往下说。所以我不得不非常严肃地坐在那里，看着史蒂夫和迈克尔把这些台词抛给我。NG花絮里有几个片段，因为要保持严肃真的很难。
I owned one. They were the best. Do you remember the little gray buttons, though, would pop off? Yep. Yep. Yeah. And you'd have to wedge them back in. But it was fun.
而且史蒂夫玩得很开心。我看了这段的NG花絮，里面有一句很棒的台词没有用上。是因为我开始笑了才没用的吗？是的。但史蒂夫接着即兴发挥了一些类似“假装今天是圣诞节我是圣诞老人。圣诞老人想给你买点小内裤”这样的话。是的。我笑得前仰后合。
And why did we need a waterproof Walkman? Well, the idea was that you were going to get so sweaty while you were working out. But I mean, really? Okay. Yeah. Well, I guess also, Brian Baumgartner told me that when Creed would enter the bathroom with that Walkman and be completely stunned and horrified that other people were in there, it would make everyone crack up. And they had a really, really hard time just getting that,
哦，那一幕对我来说太难熬了。我觉得史蒂夫当时开始瞎编了。他就像，想要一个茶包（tea bag）吗？我都不知道那是什么。好吧，帕姆有一个访谈镜头，她解释说她现在正处于两个男友的空档期。她不需要任何性感的衣服。所以她要买一件长袍，然后把它改成一些擦手巾。我觉得她挺勤劳的。
just getting Creed in the room. They could not get Creed in. I loved Creed's talking head too, because he's listening to music while he's doing the talking head. So he's sort of like yelling over the music he's listening to. Yes. And I think it's pretty on brand that Creed would go poo in the women's restroom. You know those people, Jenna.
我觉得这太荒谬了。我心想，帕姆，买条舒服的运动裤就行了。没错。确实如此。而且，你知道的，去买几块洗脸布得了。哇。我们对这个访谈镜头的反应截然不同。
You know those people. We've had roommates. The roommate that goes and takes a dump in your bathroom instead of theirs. That's Creed. Well, now, Angie, we go back to the mall. Angela and Michael are sitting. And I love the scene so much. Michael is dying for Angela to pick something out that he can buy her.
我被冒犯了。我喜欢好的浴袍。拜托，帕姆。别把它剪了。好吧。好吧，现在梅丽尔正开车送大家从商场回家，她的轮胎爆了。可能是因为她开得太快了。我的意思是，我的角色说过多少次慢点？
He has a line where he says, can I please buy you some underwear? Yeah. So you guys, Steve wanted me to break. He was 100% messing with me. And I'd been given a very strict note from Tucker Gates and Lee and Jean that they really did not want Angela to entertain him at all. So I had to sit there very stoic as Steve and Michael just got to throw these lines at me. And there's there's a few in the bloopers because it was really hard to keep it together.
慢点，梅丽尔。是的，梅丽尔根本不爱护她的车。那个轮胎爆了。迈克尔完全不知道该怎么办。他说，帕姆，也许我们需要一个弯月扳手（crescent wrench）。根本没有那种东西。帕姆说，我来。她开始换。
And Steve was just having a great time. I watched the bloopers for this and there is a great line that didn't make it. Is it because I started laughing? Yeah. But Steve went on to improvise something along the lines of like pretend it's Christmas and I'm Santa. Santa would like to buy you some panties. Yes. And I started laughing so hard.
我来。她开始换轮胎。我们有一个来自梅根·基尔（Megan Keele）、席亚拉·贝格利（Ciara Begley）、贝瑟尼·A（Bethany A）、维多利亚·纳什（Victoria Nash）和杰米·汉（Jamie Hahn）的粉丝提问。珍娜真的会换轮胎吗？是的，我会。我也会。我曾在路边和朋友一起换过一个。一样。
Oh, that was very hard for me to get through. And I feel like Steve just started making up things. He's like, want a tea back? And I was like, I don't even know what that is. Well, Pam has a talking head where she explains that she's between boyfriends right now. She doesn't need anything sexy. So she's going to buy a robe and just turn it into some hand towels. I thought that was really industrious of her.
是的。我爸爸教过我怎么换轮胎。他让我练习，并且在我学会怎么换轮胎、检查机油和更换液体之前，绝对不让我买车。我喜欢我们的爸爸教我们如何处理汽车。我觉得这太贴心了。好吧，所以现在我们回到了办公室，伙计们，吉姆去拿酸奶，他看到了帕姆画的德怀特的素描，他知道那是帕姆画的。
I thought I thought it was ridiculous. I'm like, Pam, just get a pair of comfy sweatpants. Right. That's true. Right. And, and, you know, just go buy some wash rags. Wow. We have very different responses to this talking head.
我觉得这只是他们两人之间的一个小插曲，尽管他们并没有在一起。是的。我只是觉得这真的挺温馨的。好吧，在前三集里，他们特意没有安排太多吉姆和帕姆的互动，因为，你知道的，下周就是海滩运动会了，我们会有一个大场面。哦，是吗？他们真的很想让那成为一个惊喜。
I was offended. I love a good bathrobe. Come on, Pam. Don't cut it up. All right. Well, now Meredith is driving everyone home from the mall and her tire blows out. Probably because she was going too fast. I mean, how many times is my character like slower?
天哪，我重看了海滩运动会。我知道我们会讲到那儿，但我当时想，哇，帕姆。是的，即便如此，他们确实想要一个小插曲，让你想起这两个角色之间的温情，而这就是了，就是他看到了那张海报。你在这一集里只能看到这些。这激发了他在片尾彩蛋中的灵感，我们待会儿会讲到。我也这么觉得。是的。
Slower, Meredith. Yeah, Meredith doesn't take care of her car. That tire blows out. Michael has no idea what to do. He's like, Pam, maybe we need a crescent, Alan. That's not a thing. And Pam is like, I'll do it. And she starts to change.
慢一点，梅雷迪思。对，梅雷迪思根本不好好保养她的车。那个轮胎爆了。迈克尔完全不知道该怎么办。他说，帕姆，也许我们需要一个新月扳手，艾伦。根本没这回事。然后帕姆说，我来。于是她开始换。
I'll do it. And she starts to change the tire. We had a fan question from Megan Keele, Ciara Begley, Bethany A, Victoria Nash, and Jamie Hahn. Does Jenna really know how to change a tire? Yes, I do. So do I. And I've changed one on the side of the road with a friend of mine. Same.
我来。然后她开始换轮胎。我们收到了来自梅根·基尔、西āra·贝格利、贝瑟尼·A、维多利亚·纳什和杰米·哈恩的粉丝提问。珍娜真的会换轮胎吗？是的，我会。我也会。而且我和一个朋友在路边换过。我也是。
Yes. My dad taught me how to change a tire. He would make me practice and he would not let me get a car until I knew how to change a tire, check the oil, and replace the fluids. I love that our dads taught us how to handle our cars. I just think that's so sweet. Okay, so now we're back at the office and you guys, Jim goes to grab a yogurt and he sees Pam's sketch of Dwight and he knows it's Pam.
是的。我爸爸教我怎么换轮胎。他让我练习，如果我不知道怎么换轮胎、检查机油和更换油液，他就不准我开车。我很喜欢我们的爸爸教我们如何处理汽车。我只是觉得这太温馨了。好了，现在我们回到办公室，你们看，吉姆去拿酸奶，他看到了帕姆画的德怀特素描，他知道那是帕姆画的。
And I just feel like this is just a little moment between the two of them, even though they're not together. Yeah. I just thought it was really sweet. Well, they've purposely not had much Jim Pam interaction for the last three episodes because, you know, next week is Beach Games and we're going to have a big moment. Oh, are we? And they really wanted that to be a surprise.
而且我觉得这只是他们两人之间的一个小瞬间，尽管他们还没有在一起。对。我只是觉得这真的很温馨。嗯，在过去的几集里，他们刻意减少了吉姆和帕姆的互动，因为，你知道的，下周就是海滩运动会了，我们将迎来一个大时刻。哦，是吗？他们真的很想让那成为一个惊喜。
Man, I rewatch Beach Games. I know we'll get there, but I was like, whoa, Pam. Yeah, but even still, they did want some little moment where you were reminded of the affection of these two characters and this was it, just him seeing the poster. That's all you got in this episode. And it inspired him for the tag and we'll get to that. I think so too. Yeah.
天哪，我重温了海滩运动会。我知道我们会讲到那里，但我当时想，哇，帕姆。是的，不过即便如此，他们还是希望有一些小瞬间，让你想起这两个角色之间的温情，这就是了，也就是他看到了那张海报。这集里你就得到了这么一幕。这启发了他的彩蛋，我们等下会讲到。我也这么觉得。对。
Well, something we haven't talked much about is the Andy Dwight storyline in this episode where they're going around and they're hanging up these posters and Dwight is just being so condescending to Andy the whole time, but it's very clear to Andy that this is a drawing of Dwight, so he's going along with it. Yeah. And he takes extra flyers, says he's going to put them up all over the town. And there is a great deleted scene, Jenna. It's a quick moment, but as Michael and the ladies are driving back, they come to a red
嗯，有一点我们没有怎么聊过，就是这一集里安迪和德怀特的剧情线，他们到处贴海报，德怀特全程对安迪居高临下，但安迪很清楚这画的就是德怀特，所以他就顺着演。对。他还拿了多余的传单，说要在全镇贴满。珍娜，这里有一个很棒的删减片段。那是个很短的瞬间，当迈克尔和女士们开车返回时，他们遇到了一个红
light and Michael looks out the window and sees one of the flyers on a tree and he looks at it and then looks to camera and goes, idiot. That's brilliant. So Andy's having some fun at Dwight's expense because he's going to just plaster these everywhere. And there is a great scene when at 23 minutes, 40 seconds, Andy shows Dwight a three musketeers and goes hapsies and Dwight's like, no, holsies. And he takes the whole thing in true Dwight fashion, just starts chomping down on it.
灯，迈克尔看着窗外，发现一棵树上贴着一张传单，他看了看，然后对着镜头说，白痴。这太精彩了。所以安迪在戏弄德怀特，因为他打算把这些到处都贴上。在23分40秒时有一个很棒的场景，安迪向德怀特展示了一块三剑客巧克力，说“一人一半”，德怀特说，不，我要独吞。他按德怀特的典型作风，整块拿过来就大口大口地吃起来。
Well, in one of the takes as Rain ate this candy bar this way, he choked and kind of I remember that he choked and coughed and they loved it so much. They were like, will you do it in every take? That's amazing. Well, when Michael and the women get back to the office, Michael asks Phyllis, Karen, and Pam to come into his office while he calls Jan to break up with her. Yeah, he's like, I need my girls. I love you guys.
嗯，在其中一个镜头里，雷恩这样吃这块糖时，他噎住了，我记得他噎住并咳嗽了，他们非常喜欢。他们问，你每个镜头都这么演好吗？太棒了。嗯，当迈克尔和女士们回到办公室时，迈克尔让菲利丝、凯伦和帕姆进他的办公室，同时他打电话给简要和她分手。对，他说，我需要我的女孩们。我爱你们。
Well, he gets her voicemail and he leaves a breakup message. Oh, and Jenna, your performance as Pam is so great. You're like, don't leave a message. He's like, you don't want him to leave a message, but he does. And then before he can finish it, Jan walks in. She walks in. Can you imagine? I can't imagine.
嗯，他转到了语音信箱，然后留下了分手留言。哦，珍娜，你演的帕姆太棒了。你说，别留言。他说，你不想让他留言，但他还是留了。接着在他话说完前，简走进来了。她走进来了。你能想象吗？我无法想象。
And then he's just like, all right, buddy, talk to you later. Yes, someone just walked in. And Phyllis and Karen and Pam, they clear the heck out of there. They're like, we're getting out of here. Yes. And Jan then apologizes. She says, I don't like how that phone call went earlier. So I drove all the way here to say, I'm sorry.
然后他就说，好吧，老兄，一会儿聊。对，有人刚走进来。菲利丝、凯伦和帕姆飞快地溜了出去。她们心想，我们快离开这儿。对。接着简向他道歉。她说，我不喜欢刚才那通电话的语气。所以我一路开车过来，想说声对不起。
Can we get some dinner? They awkwardly hold hands. It's such a weird moment. So weird. Steve's performance in this scene is so brilliant. When she starts listening to the message and he's kind of looking off, he has this expression on his face. It's just brilliant.
我们去吃晚饭好吗？他们尴尬地握了握手。真是个诡异的时刻。太诡异了。史蒂夫在这个场景里的表演太精彩了。当她开始听留言时，他眼神飘忽，脸上那种表情，简直绝了。
And he's just saying things like maybe we could get Italian, Chinese. Jan hears the breakup message and she leaves without saying a word. Yeah. But I went to the blogs of Jenny Tan and Kath. They have. Well, first of all, Kath said that when they started shooting the scene, Malora had on dark colored nail polish. And Greg stopped the scene because he didn't think that it fit her character
他嘴里说着也许我们可以吃意大利菜、中餐。简听到了分手留言，一言不发地转身走了。对。不过我去看了珍妮·坦和卡思的博客。她们提到。首先，卡思说她们开始拍这个场景时，玛洛拉涂了深色指甲油。格雷格叫停了这场戏，因为他觉得这不符合她的角色
and he had them change it. Oh, wow. And she noted how impressed she was at his attention to detail that everything mattered. The smallest details mattered. And I can imagine if that nail polish was distracting to Greg, it might be distracting to an audience member and it would take you out of this scene. And being in this scene with these two characters was so important. Yeah.
并让她换掉了。哦，哇。她指出自己对他的注重细节印象深刻，所有事情都很重要。最小的细节也很重要。我可以想象，如果那个指甲油让格雷格分心，那观众也可能会分心，这会把大家带出这场戏。而和这两个角色一起在这个场景中是非常重要的。对。
That would have been weird to me to see Jan with dark nail polish. I would have been thrown by that. Well, Jenny Tan said that while they were shooting this scene, they gave Malora and Steve the option of doing alternate endings. And that in one, Malora threw something and in another one, she growled at him. She just growled at the end. Growled? Growled.
对我来说，看到简涂着深色指甲油会觉得很诡异。我会觉得出戏。嗯，珍妮·坦说，在拍这场戏时，他们给了玛洛拉和史蒂夫尝试不同结局的选择。其中一个结局里玛洛拉扔了东西，另一个结局里她对他低吼。她最后就低吼了一声。低吼？低吼。
And in another one, she broke down crying. And they were watching the taping with Jean and Lee, the writers, and Jean and Lee asked them their opinion. And that she and Kath said that they both felt that Jan would be more mad than sad. And they were so excited when they saw the final cut, because they felt like they had a little part in picking the ending of the scene. Well, I thought it was the perfect ending. But I think Jan is not going to spiral out in an office where she is everyone's superior.
在另一个结局里，她崩溃大哭了。他们和编剧让、李一起观看了拍摄带，让和李问了他们的意见。她和卡思都觉得简会是“愤怒”多于“伤心”。当她们看到最终剪辑时兴奋极了，因为她们觉得自己对选择这个场景的结局也有点小小的贡献。嗯，我觉得这是最完美的结局。但我觉得简不会在一个她是所有人上司的办公室里崩溃发飙。
Yeah. And in front of the cameras. Oh, yeah. I feel like the part, like once she got in her car, maybe it was a different story. But she wasn't going to let them see too much. So the episode is wrapping up. We have Michael's talking head and Jean and Lee said this was actually a series of three talking heads that they meshed together.
对。而且是在镜头前。哦，对。我觉得一旦她上了车，可能又是另一回事了。但她不会让大家看到太多。所以这一集就要收尾了。我们看到了迈克尔的访谈，让和李说这其实是一组合成在一起的三个访谈片段。
And then they had all this B-roll when he's like, he wished for Jan to get over him and Phyllis to get a plasma TV, for Pam to get courage, and Angela to get a heart, and Kelly to get a brain. Yeah. All of these moments. I just loved it. I thought it was like such a great way to wrap up the episode. And now, Jenna, let's discuss the tag.
然后他们准备了所有这些B面镜头，他说，他希望简能走出阴影，菲利丝能买上一台等离子电视，帕姆能重拾勇气，安吉拉能拥有一颗心，凯利能拥有一个大脑。对。所有这些时刻。我太喜欢了。我觉得这是给这一集收尾的绝佳方式。好了，珍娜，我们来聊聊彩蛋吧。
You told me that it was actually Randall Einhorn who pitched this tag. Yes. Who pitched the idea of the Sharpie on the mirror, right? Yes. So in this tag, Jim calls the sex predator hotline. He has information. Dwight answers the phone. And Kath noted in her blog that it took rain six takes to get out the line
你告诉我其实是兰德尔·艾因霍恩提出了这个彩蛋的构思。是的。是关于镜子上马克笔涂鸦的点子，对吧？对。所以在个彩蛋里，吉姆打给性罪犯热线。他有线索。德怀特接了电话。卡思在她的博客里提到，雷恩拍了六条才把台词说顺
Dunder Mifflin slash sex predator hotline. This is Dwight Shrew. I'm saying it like because it was making them laugh. And Jim tells Dwight that he saw the perp in the woman's bathroom above the sink. And this is Jim. This is Jim and Pam having a prank with each other without even knowing it. They're just missing each other. Because Dwight runs in the bathroom, he looks in the mirror.
“丹德米夫林兼性罪犯热线。我是德怀特·施鲁特。”他当时说得怪声怪气的，因为大家都在笑。吉姆告诉德怀特他在女洗手间的洗手池上方看到了嫌疑人。这就是吉姆。这是吉姆和帕姆在不知情的情况下互相整蛊。他们只是擦肩而过。因为德怀特冲进洗手间，照了照镜子。
And this was Randall's pitch that there would be a little Sharpie mustache and Dwight would take off his glasses and realize that he is the person on the flyer. It's so great. It's so great. You know, I think it would have been funny without the Sharpie, but the Sharpie nails it. The Sharpie makes it. So that was a phenomenal idea by Randall Einhorn. Well, that was women's appreciation. Do you guys feel like you appreciate women more?
这就是兰德尔的创意，镜子上画了小小的一撇马克笔胡子，德怀特摘下眼镜，意识到自己就是传单上的那个人。太棒了。太棒了。你知道的，我觉得没有马克笔也会很有趣，但马克笔绝对是点睛之笔。马克笔太绝了。所以这是兰德尔·艾因霍恩一个绝妙的点子。好了，这就是“女性赞赏日”。大家觉得自己现在更懂得欣赏女性了吗？
I hope so. I had two things I was tracking, Jenna, and I feel like I should share them with you now. Please. First of all, Pam's plant at reception. There's not. It's not a new container. I'm sure the plant is new, but we have recycled a container. Which one is it this week?
希望如此。珍娜，我有两件留意的事，我觉得现在应该跟你分享一下。请讲。首先，帕姆在前台的那株植物。不是。不是新容器。我相信植物是新的，但我们循环利用了一个容器。这周是哪一个？
It is the indigo purple one with polka dots. Callback plant container. I know riveting you guys, but I'm obsessed. The other thing I tracked. Sorry to parents with children listening, maybe earmuffs. Here is our penis count. Oh, great. So this is the actual times we say the word penis.
是那个带有波点图案的靛紫色花盆。这是回忆杀植物容器。我知道这让大家觉得无聊，但我太痴迷了。我留意的另一件事。抱歉，如果有带小孩的听众在听，可能需要捂住耳朵。这是我们的“阴茎”计数。哦，太棒了。所以这是我们说出“阴茎”这个词的真实次数。
Not all of the other ways we talk about it, because we talk about it in a lot of different ways in this episode. Okay. Michael says penis twice and Dwight says penis four times. We actually only say the word penis six times in the whole episode. See, so if your grandma hadn't turned this off, she would have only had to hear it five more times. Didn't matter. Didn't want to hear it one time. Click off finished. Well, and now we're finished. But we'll be back next week with Beach Games.
不是指我们讨论它的其他方式，因为我们在这一集里用很多不同方式讨论过它。好吧。迈克尔说了两次“阴茎”，德怀特说了四次“阴茎”。其实我们在整集中只说了六次“阴茎”这个词。看，所以如果你的外婆没有关掉这集，她也就只需要再多听五次而已。这根本不重要。根本不想听一次。点击关闭，结束。好吧，现在我们结束了。但我们下周会带着《沙滩游戏》回归。
Beach Games is so great, and Jen Salata is going to send in some audio clips. She has some phenomenal stories. I can't wait. Can't wait. We'll see you then. See you guys. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher.
《沙滩游戏》太棒了，珍·萨拉塔会发来一些音频剪辑。她有一些精彩的故事。我等不及了。等不及了。到时候见。大家再见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwool、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。若想免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。